hey everyone Dave Volo here and in
today's video we are jumping back into
hell's Paradise to explore the second of
four amazing arcs and the first part of
this amazing world we learned all about
Gabby Mario his complex thoughts
everyone that would venture to the
island and take part in the emission the
current Society this universe is
situated in and finally the weirdest
ease of this mysterious island that
ended with us meeting one of these
so-called Immortal beings with all this
small stuff out of the way now though
and the second Lord tension Arc we can
finally dive into the initial well I
guess truth that we kind of learn about
the world and learn more about every
single character that is still alive on
this brutal yet stunning and interesting
Island as we learn more and more we
discover that a majority of the religion
and the structure of the island is
merely Not What It Seems and actually
there is in fact something far far more
Sinister at work behind the scenes but
before I spoil everything right here and
now if you are new around here then make
sure you hit that subscribe button and
let me know what other series you'd like
to see covered in detail in the future
streets are apparently sane have started
steel will run but you know who knows
plus push this video to 5K likes so that
I know you're loving these videos You'll
absolutely destroyed it last time with
the light goal on the you know previous
house Paradise video same with the one
punch man video so you know don't worry
I've seen you all over there and I've
been working on something in the
background it's just it's extremely long
as well but um of course you know if
you'd like to you can also check out my
patreon to get early access to these
Cinema length videos but for now sit
back and relax as we take a cliff dive
straight back into the twisted and Dark
World of Hell's Paradise
back with gibbimaru as they look over
the village the ninja states that it did
not matter what was living on the island
what matters is that the inhabitants are
allies or enemies directly behind the
main group a girl in a hood is seen
watching them from behind a tree gaming
our returns and notices someone causing
his spy to run off but Gabby manages to
quickly catch the spy and after removing
the hood discovers that it's just a
young girl Wally wonders if it's someone
who's native to the island a branch
comes through and almost takes his head
off it's shown that a random looking
tree dude everyone's favorite Bonsai man
kinda like Groot from Guardians of the
Galaxy had managed to push Gabby back
thinking that the girl might know
something about the island Gabby Mario
decides to run after her he manages to
dodge another thundering Blow from the
tree before spinning in the air and
using the back of the monster to boast
himself towards the girl since the Gary
is like still caught up on the original
missions hierarchy she quickly runs
after him and leaves the rest to use a
riha and Center use a rehab being a
sneaky kunuichi she is flixoff sent his
glasses so we can't see her abilities
and decides to take on the tree monster
within ninjutsu 2. nearby Gabby Mario
manages to catch up to the girl but is
he asked to just have a chat as shocked
by his strength after she picks him up
before throwing him into a tree sagiri
yells to her that they did not intend to
harm her however the girl stops in the
forest turns and throws a punch towards
her Gabby Mario blocks his punch but as
he tries to push back notices that she
is using a mysterious power behind your
attacks being pushed back by this random
power Gabby starts to ponder what it
could possibly be ever since he came to
this island there have been so many
Mysteries he thought it'd be a simple
mission to just find The Elixir and
return home but now he's becoming
desperate Gabby Morrow then starts to
act serious and as he died to her uses
the vines behind him on the tree to
capture her before she even realizes
what had happened hang in there
restrained in the tree intimidated by
Gabby's now serious demeanor the girl
starts crying prompting siguri to tell
gabimaru to bring her down and let her
calm down seeing her in a helpless State
Governor figures that she was just an
ordinary girl user rehab then arrives
after finishing her business with a tree
monster and asked how things were going
on their end get me more I wanted to
push further with the girl about the
Elixir but scary says that it wouldn't
be possible with her crying suddenly the
tree monster started talking pleading
with them to let go of the girl and in
exchange it would tell them about the
Elixir and guide them to the Village
speaking up yusu rehab believes that it
is a trap as up until now the Bonsai
dude hadn't said anything after
persuading her by mentioning that there
is a bath though the group follow him to
the village with useria overly excited
about that said bath hanging back behind
them segeri asks Gabby whether they
should trust him or not leaf with rarely
no other options he says it's probably
best because he may know about the
Elixir but also tells her that if the
tree man is lying he will take it down
hearing the others check behind him the
tree man promises them that it will not
trick them and calm Center by letting
them know that they're monsters and
butterflies won't even come near the
village he also reveals that those
so-called monsters are like I've said
just before called the social guardians
of this island according to the master
tree they provide wisdom and punish
those who turn from the teachings he
himself isn't one of them but instead
used to be human and was raised on the
island so these ocean things are
actually called kamadogami in Japanese
they are known as trude deities of a
kitchen and household and Chinese
mythology and taoism funnily enough the
most famous of all of the social deities
was Zao Jun who also went by the moniker
kitchen God and this universe they
mainly take on the role as a fodder
monster who punish people that break the
Island's roles anyway they arrive at the
Village which at this point is really
just a town in Ruins and into the tree
man's house while yuzuruha and sigiri
take a bath which I can't really show
you guys on here let's just uh say Yuki
loves join his girls for now our
suddenly bath the others apart from
Gabby because he thinks it's poisoned
eat some delicious looking fruit moments
later both of the girls return and the
tree man goes more in depth explaining
the ins and outs of the island humans
may call the island by another name but
to him it's known as Kotaku a paradise
for the gods there is indeed an apparent
elixir of life on the island that is
found in these ancient texts here it
goes by the name tan and pretty much
means source for everlasting life the
tree man gives a layout of the island
which is broken into three distinctive
regions issue which is where they
arrived on the island Hojo which is
where the village is located and The
Elixir is located at the center of the
island called harai in our own world
this is the name for the Chinese penguy
a place said to be a mountain on a
random island in the Eastern Seas of
mythological China which was home to
eight Immortal Hermits of Tao's thoughts
crazily enough in a weirdly similar
parallel to this story during the 3rd
Century BCE a shin Dynasty sorcerer
named shufu set out on a mission to find
this pink lie and the elixir of Life
instead though some historical texts
suggest that it actually found Japan and
the mountain that would later be named
Mount Fuji continuing with our like real
world parallels both issue and Hojo the
other areas of the island in Hell's
Paradise are the Japanese names for two
Chinese fantasy Islands both Ying Zao
and Fang Zhang respectively I really
just love how much mythology and history
is waved into the story as truly
fantastic and just goes to show that
Yuki really has a great standing of his
own country's past anyways anyways
continuing forwards Gabby who still
doesn't really trust this dude asks him
have he's ever seen The Elixir but Mr
tree hasn't although he knows he
benefits from its effects cinta asks if
he's one of these Immortals then as he's
implied that he's been around for a
thousand years sitting there the tree
man just say that they will encounter
them sooner or later and once they do
their doubts will be erased for this man
Lord tencent is Forever Young undying
Beauty incarnate the perfect being at a
similar time remember how late the
brothers bumped into a couple gender
Benders well it turns out that they are
absolutely stuffed as Lord tensin was
one or both of these beings and took
great pleasure and absolutely
obliterating the pathetic humans who
stood in its way yeah so uh so let the
tree man wasn't playing they are kind of
stuffed if they bump into this Immortal
beam like Tomah and chobe were
absolutely insane especially chobe the
man didn't even care what he went up
against yet he was defeated in a matter
of moments back with the main group and
after hearing about Lord tensin Gabby
marrow and used riha Point their way
happens towards the monster believing
that it wants them to Die the tree man
corrects them though and says that it
holds no hostility only speaking the
truth about those who step onto the
island meanwhile the mysterious being
carries Tomah and chobe before throwing
him down into a pit of blooming humans
these beings are the commanders of the
social they pass judgment on mainly the
sinful humans who come to the island
once dropped into this pit it said
people are reborn as beautiful blossoms
freed from this sin and Earthly desires
granting them Everlasting Bliss those
who eventually become one with the
island are the source of tan for these
Immortals the trim improves that the
elixir does indeed Exist by breaking a
part of his hand off and showing Gabby's
crew that it can regenerate gebimaru
then points a sword towards the girl
wondering if she also benefits from The
Elixir but zakiri and yusu riha
criticize him for his rude Behavior
scolding him for pointing a weapon
towards a child the tree man proceeds to
explain that they can choose to believe
it or not but this is shin senkyo a land
of gods that fell down to this poor
State centuries ago escape from this
Island isn't possible and the gods will
be the ones to cast judgment on them
meanwhile tenza and nuruga who have been
out searching for an ocean current fail
to find one since they need to come up
with another Escape strategy they start
to play in one when all of a sudden
they're approached by an unknown woman
after noticing that the forest is indeed
full of activity she becomes enraged by
the amount of social corpses she
discovers on the island the woman's face
begins morphing as it then turns into a
man feeling threatened tenza and aruga
attempt to run buddyman instantly
appears in front of tenza and Strikes
him with some form of Sonic Boom attack
as tenza begins falling to the ground
The Godly being flashes and behind a
rugai and tries to take her out but
luckily she manages to jump back dodging
the attack tenza who's still somehow
alive then appears in front of the
creature and slashes his eyes however
it's shown that it's utterly useless as
they'd manage to heal the damage needed
to make an opening to escape tensor
rapidly slashes away at the man thinking
that'll allow him enough time to escape
with the rugai instantly though the bean
heals and once again appears right in
front of tinsur then coming in seemingly
saving the day the creature is caught
off guard by The Blind King Rank 4
Yamada Simon shion's sword throw giving
his fellow humans a moment to escape
after getting far away from the random
creature tenza introduces narugai to a
savior and a genuine blade Master Yamada
asymon Shion slapping him on the head
though she unscolds tenza for only using
his speed and a swordplay against his
opponent wanting to know why he's here
now Tinder asks Shion what happened with
his criminal originally Shion was in
charge of akaginu but after she tried to
seduce him she paid with her life which
is absolutely crazy she just wanted a
friend dude either way after leaving her
he managed to find a current that could
lead them away from the island however
he pointed out that he sent an
unfamiliar presence and heard weird
noises tenza says that the three of them
should go to the spot where he found the
current but she on raises his sword and
asked why he was helping his criminal
tinsa explains that she was innocent
however she literally isn't having it
before arriving on the island he
memorized every criminal with him and
knows what they've done even though
she's not a criminal and both of their
eyes it isn't up to them to decide what
is wrong and what is right as is the era
that they live in which decides the
crimes people commit tinsuri battles him
though and brings up how he himself used
to be just a Wanderer without any
purpose in life there was no reason for
Shion to save him back then yet he still
decided to take him off the street now
in a similar situation of his own teens
wanted to do the same for her as he sees
potential for her to live a real life in
the world remembering the past and
realizing just how far tenza had Truly
Come for the day he met him Shion is
convinced and allows his student to do
as he pleases nuruga greets her future
husband's Master by calling him Sensei
to which she on like the goatee is says
that she needn't call him there since he
hadn't taught her anything wanting to
quickly head back to the beach she on
tells tenza to chill out as they need to
be cautious of the mysterious band that
they just faced before it's best that
instead of making themselves a Target
they need to take their time and come up
with a strategy however as tenza begins
to ponder on what they should do The
Godly thing drops down into the middle
of the forest now appearing as a female
and saying that they've underestimated
Earth deadly Shion quickly moves the two
out of the way but as his throat
currently process tensor fights back yet
he's unable to hit the creature at all
as it Dives in and out of all of his
swings needing to make a stand tenza
uses his ultimate technique Ito Ryu
pounding torrent swinging his sword over
and over and over again creating an
unescapable wave of slashes the female
though is on a different level of skill
and easily manages to weave through all
of his strikes before confronting him
directly and saying that she's
accustomed to a speed tapping him in
three different places on his chest
Tinder is sadly downed by another use of
that mysterious technique leaving the
others screaming out for their falling
Ally falling into a memory from his past
Tanger recalls the time he asked Shion
why he even picked him up off the street
sheon says that Jude hell is proficient
as the end lives he likes to help out
others and soar potential in him back in
the present tensor drops to his knees
and while looking at his palms realizes
that he's currently dying from the
previous attacks as the god stands over
him it's obvious that if he doesn't do
something everyone else is going to end
up just like him screaming he rises to
his feet and attempts to fight back
throwing a fat right hook into the face
of the immortal creature he knows that
this is probably it for him but he'll do
whatever he can to make enough time for
the others to escape however tender
receives another fatal blow to his
stomach catching him completely by
surprise with nothing left to do better
than bruise Tinder tries telling the
Ruger to run but he can't probably must
have the strength to even say a word
luckily xion was able to reach out and
stop naruga from trying to help not
wanting to leave his former student
alone himself though and unable to
understand what tenza is trying to say
she even takes a stand ready to save his
wounded friend knowing that his Sensei
won't stand a chance though tenza tries
to muster just one word to tell him to
leave or run away but just like with
naruga he's unable to muster anything
but I shot Google sensing something
Shield jumps back and stops his assault
before running away with the rugai back
behind him the legend himself tenza
takes his final stand and hinders The
Immortal foe's attempts to chase the
others now deeper into the forest has
since a screams in pain while fleeing
what tens has chosen disciple and his
final moments tenza imagines what life
could have been like in the future
possibly teaching a bunch of younger
students or drinking with all of his
buddies on a beautiful day over with the
others as they flee naruka screams and
hits Shion wanting to know why why is he
leaving tenza behind well this throat's
starting to recover he explains that he
was honoring tenza's Last Wishes tenza
knew that they wouldn't be able to
defeat these creatures the way that they
are now and if they stayed they would
all have shared the same fate retreat
was the only way however he states that
this debt will be paid before they flee
the island they will destroy that
creature meanwhile over in a much more
chill atmosphere as Gabby Mario appears
to take a bath him and sigiri think back
on the moment earlier they know that
both may and the tree who goes by hoco
were born and raised on the island
they've lived here for centuries and
only wish to live in Peace Center the
big brain also knows that in China's
xinshan beliefs tensin refers to an
elite type of mystical hermit these
ocean and harai are also words
originating for the Dao so it's only
fair to say that they're probably
telling them the truth about the island
and Mainland China's actual history like
in our own world tinson was a term made
up by the Jin Dynasty scholar ji Hong
it's simply a classification for the
highest class of immortal Hermits there
are two other classifications as well
which we'll get into later into the
video now in the bath house sagiri takes
note of just how many wounds Gabby
Murray has sustained since getting on
the island looking at may she also sees
this massive SCAR or some kind of
strange marking that travels up the
majority of her back while washing
himself getting my remembers a time his
wife washed his back and gave him advice
about how to properly relax his body she
reminded him on how if he didn't take
the opportunity to relax then he's bound
to collapse in the real battle that they
call Life and Times of Peace stick to
your convictions wear them proudly at
times or conceal them at others but
never let go of what truly makes you you
for life is far far longer than even the
Battle of Kawana Kojima damn I love how
poetic you he is with this story and it
makes me want to learn just Japanese in
general as I know for a fact this story
would be so much more in-depth in a
language that is artistically based for
example this battle there Gabby's wife
referred to was actually the site of
five or possibly six different battles
there happened in the Warring States
period between 1553 and 1564. if you
want to check out like the actual
location it's situated near the present
day and Nagano the battles between
commanders Takeda Shenzhen and usigi
kinshin have become some of the most
romanticized pieces of Japanese history
giving rise to retailings reimaginings
Artistic representations and even movies
anyway after remembering how he told her
that she shouldn't cover her scar with
through here he goes the same advice to
me about the marking on her back saying
he knows this lady with a big old scar
across your face and she's the prettiest
girl around as both girls taking this
new side of Gabby it causes May to
become star struck wanted to stay by his
side instead of scared of him like he
was before leaving the bath house now
and as the three walk back to hoco's
Residence zagiri notices that kevimaru
is truly sudden to change at the same
time Gabi Maru reminds himself why he's
exactly here he'd managed to get a
breather in and finally remembered those
feelings of his but his priority isn't
to be the round no it's to make it home
and save his wife from a tyrannical
father inside of hoco's house center
who's literally fried his brain after
Gathering so much information which was
just like me on this video right here
insists that they should spend the night
as there's still so much to unravel
security tells him that he should rest
for now then but Center who's
overheating insisted that he'd be able
to keep watch after he takes a bath
however once outside and on guard Duty
he falls asleep off Gabby Maru who's
just chilling right next to him sitting
there overthinking everything that's
happened so far Gabby Mario decided that
it would be better to head out alone to
her eye before the enemy makes their
move against them as gabimara rushes for
harai he sees a number of immobile tree
creatures trotting strange sutures
amongst the fog there was a tongue
twister and a half for some reason while
walking along he wonders if they're
praying and thinks back on how Santa
said it's probably dangerous to act
before they know what's really going on
even though Gabby knows that this could
be the most dangerous place in the world
if he doesn't press on there is
absolutely no chance he'll ever see his
wife again stopping for the moment
though he wonders how in the world he's
even going to know when he arrives at
harai it's not like the Homeland with
roadsides at the same time an unknown
person is seen following him pressing
forward Gabby Morrow eventually comes to
find a massive gate remembering what
hoko said about arriving a place of
Splendor he believes that this is with
the hermit and the election must reside
just as he goes to enter the area though
he stops noticing something behind him
coming face to face both Gabby Morrow
and the same mystery various Bane who
just took out teams of steer into each
other's eyes randomly it becomes sad and
by his presence and drops to its knees
just asking him to leave explaining that
she had already dealt with capturing
another group of humans today hearing
this flicks a switch on her boy's head
and he immediately realizes just from
his statement alone that she turns
people into the elixir of life after
seeing each other as a threat the two
engage in battle jumping straight at
each other Gabby Morrow lands to a
successive blows on the woman and comes
to the conclusion that she wasn't Human
After regenerating her wounds turning
things up a notch he flips back into a
handstand spinning flame kick that lands
directly onto the face of the immortal
being he then activates the ability
nympho fire monk to completely
incinerate The Immortal while the
creature smoldering below him Gabby
Morrow noted that it was far too strong
to even consider a questioning when all
of a sudden The Godly Bane doubt
straight back out with its charred body
and leaves it erected on Gabby marrow
sending him shooting into the sky
phasing into the sky in an instant as
well and then lands another massive kick
to the gut of the Ninja thinking that
it's destroyed the human it reforms to
its normal male shell but as perplexed
when he sees Gaby Morrow standing there
asking if he was indeed Lord tencent in
a display of skill yet unseen in this
series both gabymar and the being known
as Lord tense and continue fighting in
her eye coming to a standstill for a
moment Gabby asks where the Elixir is
before diving straight back in and
throwing another series of kicks and
punches he notes that all of the damage
he's inflicting is pretty much useless
as it's regenerated by its ability just
too fast trading blows with this thing
is just like Roku Rota as well it's only
going to result in certain death what he
needs is a strategy that's actually
going to hurt her acidic Blaze didn't
work so he opts for a technique that he
hasn't tried so far he throws a small
swift kick to the gut or Tandon of the
monster and notices that the impact felt
slightly different from before somehow
it actually did some form of damage
causing low tensin to cough up blood and
transform into a Woman by the way
whenever they change into a woman I have
to do so much blurring or body
modification so like I apologize for
that Yuki himself just goes to him with
his art style and it's amazing I just I
just wish they wore like tops some
sometimes for something anyway
continuing tencent tells Gabe that he's
probably not even aware of what he just
did and changes into another fighting
form that we haven't seen so far
becoming enraged it tells him to die
before sending what seems to be an
invisible Sonic energy waves that deal
an insane amount of damage not
understanding what in the world just
happened Gabby becomes overwhelmed as
Lord tense and sends out a barrage of
attacks at levo boy with physically no
way to block unable to counter Gabby
Mario just throws away any idea of
trying to defend and grits his teeth
before charging out the immortal
creature he gets within thrown hands
range and begins doing his thing man
knows that if he survive he gets to go
home end of story that's it that's
what's going to happen even with parts
of her missing he will make it home he
speeds his attacks up through pure grit
and somehow manages to gain the other
hand before beating the false god down
onto the ground defeating it after being
defeated Gabriel tells it to talk as he
just wants to find damn Elixir however
Lord tense and smiles and as its body
begins to bloom flowers it states that
they would be furious with it again and
that moment tense and loses its natural
shape and morphs into a massive monster
made up of those previously blooming
flowers after the Lord tense and
transformation Gabby Murray calms
himself and tries to think of a strategy
however the transformed Immortal
unleashes uncontrollable bolts of
lightning that Blitz the entire area and
badly wound Gabby throwing a massive
Boulder aside Gabby doesn't hesitate and
darts back in trying to land some form
of hit on the monster but it's utterly
useless as he's blasted back once more
finding a heap of rubble he tries to
activate an acidic Blaze yet it's once
again useless as his body freezes up on
him making him realize that he's already
reached his limit and has no stamina
left at all being unable to move the
monster overwhelms Gabby causing him to
wonder if this is real or if it would
all be one long nightmare waking up
randomly in his house his wife lets him
know that had been tossing and turning
possibly having some kind of bad dream
breaking down Gabby tells her that he
had had the worst nightmare he's ever
had as time passes we see Gabby chilling
out on his Veranda while his wife brings
him some dream warding tea looking at
her he says that even if this is a dream
it's wonderful that he was able to talk
to her again while they're slowly
becoming confused with what he's saying
Gabby apologizes as he knows that there
is no chance he's ever going to see her
again sadly beckony present can be
reawakens and he grasp of the monster
moments before it seemingly crushes him
no no no no no no no no Gabby ain't done
though instead what we thought was our
boy dying was in effect him starting his
last Stitch effort while remembering a
specific ninja principle Ironclad ninja
lore rule 20 should death be upon you
and the moments before your doom
inflicts Grievous damage upon the foe
that would ring the life from you
bursting the Flames once more Gabby
knows that when facing death he gets to
surrender everything even his
subconscious having activated an impo
fire monk gabimura eventually bursts
through the monsters grip causing him to
fall to the ground below not having the
strength to even get back up Gabby Mario
just thinks of his wife and apologizes
for not being able to make it home
randomly though May then appears besides
Gaby Murray and helps some Escape by
creating a crater using a mysterious
ability allowing him to safely slide off
the cliff and rage the monster attempts
to attack the two with its lightning but
fails to hit them before they flee
reverting back to normal now Tintin just
wonders what in the world was the reason
for Meg's actions inside of her eye all
of these mysterious rulers that each and
they own can also be called Lord tensen
are gathered for a meeting about the
humans that landed on the island too far
which is one of the names for these
creatures becomes angry with sujen for
failing his guard duties and being
reduced to a Keyshia Kai State he
violently attacks him but is quickly
scolded by the leader for causing harm
to a fellow family member he brings up
that they can only punish those which
they serve and because of that he may
only harm zhujin putting the failure
that is Zoo genocide he asks jufa for
any information on the humans they've
encountered so far Drew relays on how he
dropped both chobe and Toma into one of
the perks watching their eyes is far too
deep for any human to climb out of
massive are foreshadowing I think so but
anyway Mudan who's trying to take the
role of kind of like a boss here I I
guess advises them to not underestimate
the humans if it had been just a social
that was taken out it wouldn't have been
no big deal but since they managed to
slay a Munchen things seem different
about these humans he brings up a
terrifying possibility they'd say they
were able to escape the pit Jew threw
them into then there would be nothing
more fearsome than a wounded Beast plus
of every other human on the island
wielded the same kind of strength then
they might truly face a terrible Beast
unbeknownst to these goons that's
exactly what's going on here the leader
the narsity successfully won the Battle
of the head last night what she was
certain they suddenly make a toast to
longevity and zhujin is fully restored
to his normal form so what they mean by
keshikai like I didn't mention this
earlier thought I was going to but I
didn't as the Monstrous platform that
they evolve into under great stress
which is you know like the one that we
just saw before which is also another
representation of Yin and Yang if you
look at it more like a retrospectively
the colors and all kishikai literally
means demon corpse undo which has some
kind of aspect in the story uh later on
which will bring up as well and it is a
concept inspired by ji Hong's weakest
Immortal hermit form the xinji Shian
from what I've seen in like we can
obviously get so far this story dives
into the more Chinese mythological side
of things and especially the stuff from
the psych ji Hong fellow anyways anyways
meanwhile I'm back with the main group
Center apologizes to scary for
accidentally letting Gabby Mario leave
his sight the previous night Hoku brings
up that it's almost impossible for any
ordinary human to travel through the
most but security believes that if he
did indeed sit out he may have actually
found a way to navigate the area and if
that's the case they need to find him at
once use a rehabo disagrees it's not
like they've got any time to spare
themselves and when it was a Gary was
even concerned about Gary marrow hoko
interrupts and offers to guide them
through the most seeing as how may lift
he has to go find her anyway hearing
this yuzuriha switches up and is
persuaded into finding Gabby once again
because of hoko you know you gotta love
the tree dude once they leave sagiri
notices that with Gabby having runoff
it's now beyond the scope of her duties
still she can't help but hope he's okay
elsewhere Gabby Maro awakens with maybe
side item and immediately come to the
conclusion that the thing he just fought
was no God just a living breathing
monster pleased with a realization he
stands ready to figure out a way to
defeat the beast from the battle so far
it's obvious to him that he can't do it
alone but with two three four even more
comrades it might be possible in that
moment he notices another two newcomers
appear directly behind him the GS after
encountering Tamaya against hits usai
and Yamada asymon Fuji Gabi Maru and
gentitsu Sai go back and forth
protecting each other's actions in their
heads before they make a move in the
actual battle stepping in between the
two though filchi ceases their pointless
imaginary battle and instead plans to
extract information from gabimaru having
honed a special ability since he was a
young fellow that allows him to
recognize someone's strength at a glance
Gabby Mario decides to sit down and
request an alliance with the two
gintuchusai draws a sword and swings at
it Gabby to see if he was trying to
trick them but after the previously
Hollow Man didn't Flinch at all figured
he was telling the truth still he felt
disappointed with him for Gabby showed
him just how truly weight he was and he
tells him that he wasn't looking for
cowards who'd bow to an enemy either way
Fuji asks to hear him out wanted to know
why the infamous Gabby Mario would go
this far with some randoms going over
everything that has like happened up
until this point both Fuji and
gentichusai are especially intrigued to
hear more about this random Lord tension
fellow Fuji who's just blown away with
Gabby's explanation asks how it was able
to regenerate and was there any signs
that it had internal organs not knowing
every detail Gabby says that honestly
he's not even sure what happened he just
needs to earn that pardon and get back
to a certain someone just as intrigued
himself gentitusai agrees to teaming up
and tells him that he had no interest in
the pardon but rather to become a
legendary figure that will live forever
confused because there obviously means
the dude still wants the Elixir cantizo
reiterates that literal immortality
would get boring fast what he wants is
to be able to perform beats that shake
the Earth then that way the name Tamiya
then teachers I will live on for
eternity he's a you know he's a true
historian and a true warrior you know
like that's history for you the only way
you get to really live on is people
write about you and talk about you in
the history box anyway screaming to the
sky he tells the gods themselves to
believe it one day they'll paint
pictures and write tales about a
strength Fuji who thinks his criminals
absolutely lost his mind also agrees
after learning that an undying organism
actually exists having come to their
agreement Fuji asks scary to Spill the
beams on what he knows agreeing he goes
to start off with May and explain her
yet as soon as he looks at her he's
shocked to see that she's grown a few
years in age fucci who obviously you
know hasn't met Gabby Mario so far or
may ask why Gabi Mario was shocked to
which he explained that may has aged for
some reason then after hearing her speak
for the first time getting married
quickly rushed in and grabbed her asking
if she was the same as tencent and for
more information on the Elixir noticing
how forward he was being Gabby stepped
back and thanked her for everything so
far but also a question as to why she
couldn't speak up until now at the same
time yuzuriha curiously asked hoko what
in the world Lord tencent was finally
it's explained what's absolutely
confused readers that Lord tencent is in
fact seven different Immortal beings
according to Legend it's possible that
it used to be one Immortal Bane but
obviously hoko is unsure as so much has
changed throughout the uh historical
text what's known though is that there
is the Supreme Shandi samantabhadra
Heavenly daddy ashko enthroned jujun
amokavahadra sagacious dashnig ratna
Regional
decorius gong gong mansuri and defy
Dijon Conde obviously apologies for all
of my terrible translations or
pronunciations on those perks to any of
my Indian fellows that can actually uh
speak the language obviously you guys
are insane I don't know how you do it
anyway apparently the great Herman over
a thousand years ago reached
Enlightenment achieved deification and
thus but themselves Sevenfold The
Immortal Bane's appearance and voice are
shared between them but they all vary in
personality and the role they take like
cinta mentioned in the island arc on how
it was a poor mix-up of religions and
cultures these names are exactly the
same they combine titles from Chinese
cultures and mythology mixed them with
unrelated bodice deities and their
Concepts funnily enough any Japanese
version of like the story itself they
use the Japanese pronunciations whereas
in my video you know we're like big
brain in it by my pronunciation and in
the English translation it uses the
accepted spellings from each specific
religion anyway continuing the tree man
also reveals that everyone of the island
was once human with abnormally long life
spans and comparison to the average man
yet even still with their long life
spans their prosperity ended after a
thousand years and eventually everyone
had Abba vacation once someone does
begin turning they only have a limited
amount of time before their mind goes
blank and they travel to harai to sit in
these zazin pose and chant strange
sutras hearing this information center
objects to hoko's previous statement on
the island being Shen senkyo and
believes that it's more likely based
around a man-made religion words like
harai issue and zazin and even more
tensen's titles all relate to existing
different religion spheres consider the
physical remains scattered all over the
island all of them reflect very real
human religions due to all of this he
can accept that this island is cut from
The Real World as some sort of spiritual
realm isolated for over a thousand years
he tells use riha to remember Morrow and
how he was originally arrested for
trying to overthrow the shogunate but
founded a new religion altogether just
like his weird religion the one they've
discovered here is also made up from a
distortion of different faiths and his
mind hoko's stories have only supported
his theory that this island and
everything inside of it including them
being lowered to the island are all
works of a mysterious Creator well
there's explanation in mind usuriha
believes that it's pretty much
impossible to stop someone who's been
planning everything behind the scenes
for over a thousand years and assumes
scary Mario and may are already dead
from even trying to approach it however
sigiri believes that gabimaru is very
much alive and is already formulating a
plan of action as no matter what he will
see his wife once more shishi naive
Haven segeri on that uh Gabby wife hype
train now back with Gabby hand quas as
to how in the world may save him back
there may who can't speak properly tries
to tell him that it was Dao weak strong
Spirit Fuji brings up that the tandem
which was one of the words she said
could be related to the flow of chi or
chakra but he obviously can't say for
sure on the other hand Hoku explains to
the girls that Dao is the energy that
flows through everything everything that
exists comes from the never-ending flow
of Dao and if someone is able to tap
into that flow then it could allow them
to Middle with creation itself elsewhere
shiona naruga go through some like
training exercises after getting
absolutely blitzed by The Blind King the
real guy pleads with him to explain his
swordsmanship but he refuses her as he
just couldn't bear to watch another
student fall before his eyes not pleased
naroka tells him that she can sense he
isn't any ordinary guy there was someone
in their Clan who could see with sound
but the level Shion is on is almost
otherworldly in comparison so the reason
big Shield is able to murk people were
blind is because just like taste or
smell all things in this world persist
unique waves and that's exactly what
he's able to perceive Eve the technique
is so refined that he's even able to
tell exactly what the Uruguay's
hairstyle looks like yet there isn't any
city name for this ability so he just
calls them waves so Mastery over Dao
allows the user to not only sense things
but it boosts their physical abilities
to the same level as a god tapping into
that power requires an extremely
balanced spirit so remember the stuff
May was trying to say well the strong
weak more or less mean balanced Spirit
once someone achieves Mastery over the
everflown Cycles between rage and
serenity like we saw with sargeri
against Roku Rota then they will begin
to sense the waves according to Buddhist
texts it's called the middle wave the
state of being able to draw at a power
that exceeds your natural potential
asking what the right wave is then Shion
gives her an example of how he activates
the technique he explains everything
from his stance to how he holds the
blade and even the feeling that he gets
will wielding for blade but he punches
shoshin perfectly rolling up behind
Shion he displays just exactly what he
sees tending into all the specific waves
it reveals a dark world made up of white
waves so even in and out of the darkness
creating the creatures and Landscape
around him lashing out Shion easily
takes down every single Monster all
while explaining to nurugai what goes
into the use of his technique they both
began taking on the remaining creatures
together he tells naruguay that he still
refuses to become a teacher but she is
free to learn as much as she wants from
him elsewhere Gabby Mario is also
ambushed by a large amount of social
stepping forth in one of those freaking
massive swings gentichasai takes out the
first wave of creatures with ease he
knows that he wants to learn this Dao
thing but sitting around in lessons is
so damn boring for the Beast he teases
Gabby for how beat up he's gotten since
making landfall and tells him that they
need to learn In the Heat of battle with
all of these so-called training dubbies
in front of them he asks me to jump down
and give them a few examples of Dao
though as she does so Gabby Mario
notices an unfamiliar presence among the
social so I remember that pit choban
Toma were thrown into you know a little
while back so that there was created by
Lord tensen in order to assimilate any
humans dropped inside making them one
with flowers from that they are able to
extract something called tan or more
specifically their lecture of life if
anyone tries to escape those pits of
theirs which is almost impossible due to
how just deep it is then the walls
themselves will hinder them still it's
shown that their pets weren't deep
enough for the demon brothers who
somehow managed to climb their way out
after escaping Thomas suggests to
leaving the island but choba angrily
declares that he will take revenge on
the two that put them there man doesn't
even need a strategy as from the first
battle he figured out their weakness was
the lower halves of their bodies after
offering Tomah a piece of Flesh to eat
from the pert the two brothers are
randomly taken off guard when a monster
rolls up and starts chatting as if it's
a part of the conversation not meaning
to frighten them the random looking
thing dressed in the Chinese outfit
tells them to not lash out as it
possesses some form of intelligence
instead of fighting they should just
talk so this thing here is actually used
for scouting purposes and a bunch of
them have been sent out to all of these
still alive humans on the island unlike
this ocean which are incomplete beings
they lack any thought or emotion and
aren't even allowed inside of her dry or
the Munchen who act as guards for the
area they are the Doshi direct Disciples
of Lord tencent who possess intelligence
and are taught directly by one of the
seven the Doshi explains that he was
ordered to assure that they were still
on the pit becoming tan while his other
comrades were outlooking and the other
humans on the island he then just
casually asks for the two to return to
the poet however chobe responds by
driving forth and attacking the creature
easily dodging a slow Blow by the Doshi
chobo lashes out disarmony monster and
causing it to jump backwards knowing
that this thing is in touch with timson
Toby demands that it tell him everything
about those freaks but the Doshi refuses
calling my foolish idiots banging in
some backup a commandsly social to take
out the humans so he can return them to
the pert not bothered by the freaking
social though chobe orders Tomah to
fight with this toshim while he handles
the Doshi himself as the two continue to
scuffle it's revealed that chobo's
attacks are causing almost no harm to
the Doshi because he doesn't wield down
this leaves a perfect opening for the
Doshi to fatally wound trobe striking
him in their face causing them to full
face first onto the ground below seeing
his bro fall down turbo becomes
horrified screaming at its name hitting
up he runs at the Doshi who's taunting
him when all of a sudden chobe reopens
his eyes the Doshi leans down to drag
him back to the perk when simultaneously
chubby awakens and spins on the floor
facing his opponent before striking a
blow directly to his face looking at his
brother Toby tells Homer to return to
fighting the father loses while he deals
with his Fame the Doshi notices that
chobo's throat has regenerated from the
previous damage and well baffled to
Deuces that during his time in the pert
he must have been affected by the vines
that infused some kind of tan into him
looking at him some more the Doshi takes
note that it's probably the case since
his dowels change shape in such a short
period of time realizing how dangerous
he could be of chobey hasn't dealt with
now he reignites the battle against the
newly evolved human instantly he breaks
his arms by manipulating the Dow around
his body but just as quickly chobe
manages to regenerate them and Strike
Back the Doshi questions with the chobe
feared losing his Humanity after his
transformation but the demon brother
states that he couldn't care as nothing
in this world set in stone fixing his
statement he says no there is one thing
that never changes that's always current
but pointed out that someone like him
wouldn't understand where he was coming
from he charges forward asking to see
more of this new power yet this time
he's actually able to visualize what the
doshi's invisible attacks look like he
then strikes the monster's navel causing
damage and showing proof to him that
weakness does indeed lie within the
stomach so these Doshi fellow are kind
of like The Messengers and personal
assistants to these tense and fellows
the word that they originate from Doshi
or dausi in Chinese is a blanket term
that refers to Taoist priests monks and
Masters back in the battle and as chobes
down begins to grow larger and larger
the though she becomes frightened trying
to call forth his social to save him but
sadly for a little Doshi it shown that
the other bro had managed to dispose of
all of them well in fourth a little Dow
he has left the Doshi creates some kind
of energy orb but is unable to use it as
his hand is crushed by chobay staring
into the terrified soul of this pathetic
creature trebe states that he now knows
how to manipulate his Dow it's simple he
brings it in from the the environment
around him with nothing left to do chobe
activates the exact same ability the
Doshi just used perplexing the creature
who thought it was utterly impossible
now seeing the waves of Dao in a similar
way to that of Xi'an chobe Smiles
knowing just how weak his enemy is
before finally dealing the finishing
blow while chobab begins interrogating
what's left of this Doshi creature Tomah
looks closely at the markings on his
brother's neck and notices that they are
beginning to spread snapping his head
towards his brother Tomah gets
frightened by chobe but soon comes out
of the days he found himself in walking
in to help type the Doshi Toma takes an
even closer look at chobe's Nick and
notices that his scars look plant-like
meanwhile while fighting off the ocean
gentitsusai asks May if he was starting
to understand Dao but may shakes her
head in disagreement stating that he was
focusing too much on strength looking
over at his Fierce rival who's
absolutely destroying the other social
he asks if he was starting to understand
Dao just like himself though may also
states that he was also focusing too
much on strength Fuji who's like off to
the side examining the remains of the
creatures becomes the delighted with his
inspection of his social anatomy and
relays the information to Gabi Maru he
finds it odd that even creatures who
share the same outward appearance have
completely different anatomical
structures from there alone he's able to
deduce that each opponent they go up
against has its own weak point however
that doesn't exactly explain what may is
as well in their eyes after remembering
how she helped him Escape Gabi marrow
comes to the realization that no
ordinary human would have been able to
pull off the feed that she did when they
escaped funnily he intently looks
towards her wondering what she is but as
May sees him it causes her to break down
and begin crying for a fourth time this
always gets me but as gabian can't hear
so I continue taking out fodder's ocean
he asks Tamaya if he was married as well
and the big man lets him know that he
has wives all over the continent
absolutely freaking King but anyway
anyway taken by surprise get into the
society then blocks A Sneak Attack by
Doshi trying to strike back he swings
his hook on towards the creature but he
was sadly unable to stop it from waving
between his attacks and taking May off
his shoulder now back a fair distance
from the main group The Doshi Greeks May
in a polite manner stating that it been
searching for her in secret for
centuries after she vanished from her
eye it caused the Doshi to fall into the
spear as they were unable to search for
her publicly due to Lord Ryan's orders
now that they've finally reunited he
begs her to return to harai as they are
engraved need of her Aid hmm so I wonder
what in the world may could possibly be
or the relation that she has to the
Immortals in her eye what do the Doshi
new do for so desperately and who in the
world is this Lord Rian fellow still so
many Christians of course like with us
being almost a third through this story
here I'd love to know your thoughts on
it all down below I find some of the
things get repeated quite a lot but
that's always going to happen when
you've got like three or four different
groups or needed to learn the exact same
information so hopefully I was able to
slim down the repeat info here and there
and make it more concise though the way
Yuki does it where it swaps around
between characters as he's explaining
parts of the world is really damn good
and I can't wait to see what the anime
does with it because I think it'll be
quite exciting on how they like skip
around between characters as they're
learning what it actually is it was just
hard for me to portray here but either
way continuing forward wanting to know
what in the world is going on Gabby
marrow and us that they Doshi tell them
what may is firstly it tells them that
it is none of their concern as Mei is
not supposed to be near humans yet since
they helped with their return it says
that she is similar to Lord tensin one
nourished by the lives of humans finding
out that she isn't human pushes Gabby to
the edge because he knows they're
getting caught up in something he
doesn't understand will only result in
death he needs to remember why he took
this Mission but after seeing the tears
beginning to fall from May's face he
rushes to his side and puts himself
between her and the Doshi creature he
knows that ETI not impulse is usually
the last thing he would do yet despite
not having any association with her he
can't bear to make her cry again furious
with this interference the Doshi
Partners himself with another similar
looking goom and declares they will turn
them into tan and retrieve May if that's
truly the case after noticing the second
doshi's appearance and how it
manipulates he bugs around them and
tetsusai realizes that he's the mofo
that made him lose his hand he's the
butterfly boss watching the two Doshi
summon a swarm of their respective
insects Gabby quickly comes to the
conclusion that they're able to
manipulate the insane takes around him
before he could strategize any further
gently steps in and cuts down the
butterflies and states that he seeks
revenge on the butterfly Doshi for
causing him to lose his left hand he
lunges in for another attack angered by
the fact that he had to refine his sword
style but is hit by an invisible attack
but they seem to pay Doshi their grazes
the side of his face initiating a close
hand battle the two Doshi charged fourth
pushing our boys back into a defensive
fight bug sweep in and out of the
battlefield in combination with hidoshi
blocking their vision and causing them
to accidentally end up hitting each
other while the boys bickering between
each other now the second Doshi watches
they do controlling this centipedes asks
to as why they wanted to protect May
despite not having any connections with
her Gabi marrow knows that if it was the
old him he would have just left her as
soon as possible but now he wonders as
to why he's begun changing ever since he
landed on the island accepting this as
they knew him he replies to the creature
that he was just repaying he did he
didn't flipped the conversation back on
the Doshi curious as to why he was so
fixated on a girl that doesn't want to
even leave with him they seem to be
Doshi explains that his kind and train
themselves in the way of Doubt just like
the Lord tension does for them may is a
key component to their training and the
ways of Dao there are five acidic
methods to training one's body in Dao
which makes me wonder if Gabby's acidic
form is also one of these five methods
or something but going paisoku shuitsu
and shoutin are the first four and you
can train him all by yourself however
the most important of them all is hot
steamy botchi Jutsu which as you can
probably pick up on demandsi Partner of
opposite gender this is due to how I
brought up earlier in the video for the
cycle of Yin and Yang to complete a
demand's intimate Congress what's
actually really cool is that these five
meditation methods come from real life
Chinese history through both Taoist and
XI Jong practices all things inside of
this world possess Chi either of Yen or
Yang Affinity even those that do not
live the higher levels of a specific
Affinity will result in an even greater
level of Dao when someone performs spots
Jutsu doing or Dolan I don't know how to
say it properly someone tell me down in
the comment section below I'm probably
completely wrong taisoku and similar
things will repair someone's mind and
body but a method to join both is
through bochujutsu those who are able to
hone their Dell through this method
unlock the ability to reshape the fabric
of reality Lord tensin has apparently
achieved this level of power and is now
an ascended band and watched the entire
Yen and yang cycle flows unbroken thus
it has been this way for the past 1 000
years as Lord tencent manifests the
ultimate Dao the reason that they need
May is because the Doshi are made up of
Yang energy and in order for them to
complete their training they require
maze assistance since she possesses Yin
Energy may and their eyes is a failure
as one of the tencent as instead of
possessing both yin and yang May was
only able to produce Yen aligned Chi
therefore Lord Rian banished her from
the palace and offered her two different
options either she could pass away or
obviously like she chose reforge herself
from the start as their training partner
which is utterly disgusting when you
think about it I'm purposefully like not
going into depth on certain aspects of
things or showing half the panels here
otherwise this video will be taken down
and I want it to stay up obviously and I
want it to be like fit for younger
audiences so that they can understand
the story in a uh and a friendlier way
not in a such a dramatic way that Yuki
puts it in sometimes so you know if you
guys want to get it and and Yuki's way
obviously go out there and read the uh
the actual manga but obviously like I'm
dumbing down things here because like
the reality of a situation is just sad I
can fully understand why Mei wanted to
break down after being threatened with
going back that's all I'm gonna actually
say on that and end that there hearing
all of this though both Gabby Mario and
getting tips with site like myself
become disgusted with this information
and good to my tells him that he'll take
on this centipede creep but looking at
his boy he's Blown Away to see just how
enraged he also is stepping in and
asking if she's marked he tells him to
stop at the rude explanation of May and
treat her like a proper normal person
not an object not bothered with the
threats of a human though the Doshi
transforms into its shikai form and
declares that they will take them out on
this spot Gente suicide and makes the
first attack jumping up and swinging at
the butterfly Doshi who retaliates by
sitting in a swarm after him he notices
that they're easier to attack when
bunched up but gets caught off guard by
the powder coming off the butterflies
slowly becoming dizzy he asks figure
bimaru's assistance but gets told to
deal with it by himself as he's just as
busy with fighting the other Doshi
shooting at an attack itself the Doshi
uses a similar blast her Lord tense and
to push give him Maru back yelling to
his teammate gained his side lets him
know that the butterflies are dangerous
hearing him kebimaru uses nimpo pyro
bridge to expel a torrent of fire that
seemingly Burns all of the butterflies
and soaks the Doshi in a cloak of flames
looking at his enemy Gabby realizes that
he wants stand a chance unless he finds
a way to sense Dao yo so uh remember
Fuji who's just been chilling here this
whole time with May in the middle of
this well after interpreting her words
from earlier Fuji yells out to gamimaru
that he's focusing too much on strength
to perceive Dao your heart must accept
both strength and weakness and unless he
accepts his weaknesses he won't learn it
may also help fuchsi sense his own GAO
by touching his hand and giving a
demonstration on how she uses it Gabby
Murray tries doing the same with her but
once she activates her Dao he can only
slightly feel something however that's
it he can't see it yet after hearing May
state in her own weird way that weakness
gives birth to strength Gabby Mario is
reminded of sagari's words and how his
love for his wife that he thought was a
weakness is actually a strength finally
understanding what the strong weakers
that may keeps going on about Gabby
Mario watches as some form of glowing
energy appears around his hand stepping
forth towards the heat of battle the
previously hollow man tells future that
he thinks he gets the gist of it now
watching him walk ahead of them may
notices just how large Gabby maru's Dow
truly is having felt the sensation
before Gabby Mario was able to see the
invisible attacks from the Doshi and
Dodges them with ease Blown Away with
just how quickly he caught on again
teaches her states that it's probably
true to the specific training he went
through as a member of the iwakore
apparently the people there even have
other worldly moves and in human forms
that they can take on at a moment's
notice it's likely that it's not exactly
Dao but possible the techniques are
based on similar principles however May
shakes her head in disagreement as he
continues to fight the centipede Doshi
Gabi Murrow begins to understand how Dao
works and begins perceiving everything
around him not just the stronger Aura
but also the weak and dying ones he also
manages to understand why he perceives
sigiri as such a terrifying Force even
with all of her doubt she still pushes
forth making her a stronger person well
this centipede Doshi through any fat
right hook towards Gabby marrow our boy
just puts his hand out and simply blocks
the strike being able to distinguish
every insector part that makes up the
monster's form he then reverses the
polarity of the monster's doubt
exploding the arm of its sheikhai form
now with the upper hand Gabby dots up
and screams now the pathetic Doshi no
longer stands a chance spinning a mid
ear Debbie Lane's a fat Kick that pushes
the creature completely out of its Chico
form feeling gassed up now Gabby tells
the centipedoshi that he's finally ready
to throw some hands with him Master
laying there on the ground now after
being defeated hidoshi Compares
gabimaru's abilities to their of Lord
tensions Blown Away with just how
accurate he was with his strikes annoyed
getting married to Mars that they don't
she tell him who he was working with and
where he can find this Lord tension see
no other option the Doshi explains to
itself along with two other Doshi were
ordered by Lord tensin to observe the
humans that arrived on the island they
were to discover how this new group
deferred to those that had made landfall
in the past mainly though it was to
assist if leaving the humans alone would
suffice or if they could present a
threat wanting to make the final blow
himself again teach decide swoops and to
steal the day with Gaby Murray turning
around to look at him the two Doshi used
their ability to attack our boy while
his guard was down Gabby though having
achieved Bliss precedes the attack and
quickly manages to jump off against each
side towards the butterfly Doshi falling
down upon him now Gabby uses his ninpo
Stone storm to Pivot his opponent while
simultaneously to my again teachers are
kills the centipede Doshi with Dao still
a mystery to him Gabby Maro figures that
if he experiments more with her he can
find a way to damage his enemies since
they can't question the like obviously
Mercado now that she considers asking
May for more information but ganti
suicide thinks it would be best for her
to return home having saved his life
twice Gabby Mario wanted to repay his
gift to May by going along with whatever
she wanted to do knowing of the notes
that taguero had read it on Gabby before
the machine had begun but she notices
that his behavior is different from what
she had interpreted and wonders if this
new soft side of him will help him on
his mission suddenly though Gabby Mario
begins bleeding from the nose before
collapsing to the ground confusing
everyone around him this is for the fact
that Dao is life force itself to employ
it in battle is to eat away at one's
life force using too much will cause the
backlash to not only affect someone's
body but even their soul this is for the
simple fact that their body and soul are
one and the same they're a manifestation
of Dao meanwhile in harai one of the
seven essential in riyan the new
training area which features an indoor
pool after presenting the final part of
the room which was like the baltujutsu
chamber you know like the old sneaky
room and other tints and criticizes how
ridiculous the idea was but Rihanna
Jake's saying that by copulating with
others it can bring out new powers too
far then comes out of the chamber
absolutely covered in some stuff after
having gone an absolutely insane session
with another tencent and is offered tan
to recover after grabbing a fresh glass
of the immortality liquid jufa asks
Rhian about mudan's whereabouts to which
it's revealed the esekiri enters the
gate to harai Mudan had gone to confront
theme upon entering the Gateway zagiri
usuryha Center and Hoku don't initially
see Mudan as instead they're Blown Away
by just how weird their surroundings are
bringing them all back to reality though
Mudan waves his hand causing hoko's head
to fall clean off finally so like with a
bunch of these names actually revealed
here I can tell you how dope Yuki
actually is so each of these tencent's
true names refers to Chinese names for
flowers riyan is lotus Mudan is peony
zujin which is the other guy's name I
didn't mention I'm pretty sure is
hibiscus and jufa is chrysantheum which
itself fits into like the whole theme of
fake Beauty like I'm not entirely Caden
with the flower meanings themselves but
from what I read online their meanings
almost perfectly reflect how each
specific tension tries to act with the
outgoing appearance and all that kind of
stuff so elsewhere and back on the
mainland in any Satsuma domain and after
learning of his return from the island
the shogun's officials ask Yamada Simon
zika about the events that had occurred
chica explains that before they even
arrived on the island choba killed his
assigned criminal so with a heavy heart
he had chosen to return back from the
mission even still the current had
forced him to the islands eventually
though the man did make it home after
cutting this story short about how he
even managed to escape an official
begged him to explain in detail about
what exactly happened during his Escape
but jika refuses saying that explaining
it would only be Troublesome and he no
longer wanted to be involved with that
hellish Place Another Yamada a Simon
then interrupts and Bows while
apologizing for jika's Behavior knowing
that the Yamada knelt before them as an
any ordinary man the representative
overlooks his offense and reads a
message from the Shogun ordering more
assignment to travel to the island after
the meeting Jacob complains to like the
star war was Anakin wannabe over here
how the essemen were being treated as
pawns but a young bloke Shogun ripped
reminds him for his behavior towards the
officials hearing cheek is half-laxed
reply about shugen's presence being a
help to him in the meeting Shogun
becomes Furious and tells him to change
his attitude as it is unbefitting for a
samurai chica apologizes and then like
obviously instead of pushing the issue
further inquires as to what
reinforcements that bring along on this
journey to the island sugar informs him
that instead of criminals the Shogun
plans to hire ninja from iwag akure
during the time chica was returning from
the islands another screening was held
to gauge the average strength of
criminals once the battle commenced
every single one of the criminals was
annihilated by iwaka Croatian Obi the
reason for their involvement in the
return to the island is because and
obviously the chief wants to make
certain of someone's demise shugen
explains they all make for the islands
in a few days and bring a swift end to
the mission having walked outside now a
random dude then comes up to jika asking
what they should do what the random
giant monster here that he had brought
back from the island Jake is like
actually goated man's so cooked that he
completely forgot to even bring up the
evidence he managed to grab off fleeing
the island either way he states to them
that it never really felt like the right
time to reveal the literal monsters he'd
fished out of the ocean walking up sugar
then takes a closer inspection curious
as to what in the world it is but he
worker warned him that it might be alive
however the anakin-looking wannabe State
the creature was indeed deceased as he
couldn't sense any waves of Life Force
coming from it honestly you know I keep
bringing up the whole Anakin thing but
like when I first read through it at
this exact point and without even
knowing his backstory yeah I feel like
this dude had just murked a whole
village or something it just has that
weird demeanor about him you know what I
mean like he's just got something going
he's just he's just a little bit odd
nearby and after having met with two
shadowy figures it's confirmed that they
ranked to shugen and rank 3G kit will be
joining them on a journey to the island
that's based purely on someone's ability
skipping back to like the moments before
our main crew entered her eye so after
traveling for a day sagiri used a reha
center and Hoku finally managed to reach
the gates of Ryan just like before
they've taken the odd surroundings when
all of a sudden a random figure in front
of them cuts off hoco's head from a
distance Mudan crawly jokes that he's
impressed with him as they're the first
humans and over a millennium who have
made it inside of Rye usury has senses
everything in front of them definitely
wasn't human and attempts to flee but
it's caught in an instant by him siguri
draws her sword and demands he'll use a
rihad go when from the ground below hoko
states that he is Lord tension the peony
Spirit enthroned fuku jukon obviously we
know him as modan one of these seven
gender Benders and as he looks at the
tree quickly figures that hoko was still
alive however due to his size being
reduced to only his head now he tells
the others that his arbification process
will only speed up from that point
onwards Hoku accepts his fate since he
obviously believes that his soul will
rest and her eye yeah and probably the
biggest gut punch for the Bonsai King
mudon Smiles stating that the religious
beliefs of his were all lies in order to
maintain the peace and structure on the
islands in truth every living thing on
the island was the result of
experimentations and the humans that
venture to the Islands were merely
research materials leading into let that
entire theory of just research materials
on humans coming up behind him he
presents the kiyoshi as examples of his
experiments by the way these Kyoshi are
like Yuki kaku's messed up take on the
historical zhangji or Chinese hopping
zombie or vampire so they're just you
know like an interesting parallel that
Yuki is going to chucked into the story
again anyways while the others disgusted
with what he's done moodhan stakes and
he just loves tinkering around but this
isn't even half of what he could do and
that the higher quality humans usually
become tan hearing him bring up this
random tan thing scented questions if he
was actually talking about the elixir of
Life quickly realizing what Center was
referring to mudon tells him that it
does exist yet The Elixir doesn't
actually benefit humans as it will only
turn them into trees so if they are
actually here for that then there isn't
any chance they'll find what they're
looking for after hearing this piece of
information sigiri worries over Gabby
Maro as now it doesn't even seem like
there's a way to complete the mission
breaking a train of thought though mudon
just asked that they surrender as their
mission has ended here catching him by
surprise slow user rehash substitutes
herself for an oblified tree appearing
directly behind him she throws a bunch
of kunai into the back of mudon then as
she begins to fall pulls out a swordball
chanting and slices The Immortal beam
just as quickly darting away from the
monster she grabs Security's shoulder
turning the direction she was facing and
telling her that they need to escape
while they have the chance with the
others trying to Gap at a regenerating
mood on comments that she's extremely
impressive but got one thing wrong the
kiyoshi are not servants but toys a game
with a flick of the wrist mood on
commands to kiyoshi to jump at yusu riha
and detonate upon coming into close
contact getting caught between the two
of them use the riha only barely manages
to avoid the explosion rising to her
knees muda knows that though she's
hidden it extremely well she can already
perceive Dao wanting to back up his girl
sent his steps forth telemund their
effortless concerns her life and death
then he'll have to go through him
becoming intrigued The Immortal comments
that if user reacts the episode for it
then he'll teach you how to properly
wheel down if not then she'll make
quality tan either way having watched
cinta step out in front of her prepared
to put his life on the line to Gary
wonders if he had any attachments to use
with her not interested in anyone but
the Shinobi mood and rushes towards
sagiri telling her to move aside before
launching her across the area using a
distant strike turning his attention to
use ariha mooden asked if she observed
How We Gather down together before going
any further though Center who's like way
quicker than I have expected cuts off
both of mudon's hands saying that he
will have to get past him first jumping
in from behind usury hotels the number
five to back off before using an impost
slime strength to trap the creature
wondering what could possibly work on
him she uses nympho nectar poison to
melt away the immortal shell then
follows up and annihilates the rest of
him with an impo Grim garot from five in
himself is a bunch of thorns he taunts
you to reho calling her application of
Doubt nothing more than a child's
flailing around thinking that if they
keep him blinded they might stand a
chance Santa cuts the top part of
mudan's head but it's utterly useless as
he taunts them while blind he also
ceases the Regeneration of his eyes and
Dodges every single one of their attacks
Gacy and next to use a riha he grabs her
leg and swings you towards Center
knocking him both to the ground the
reason that Mudan is able to comfortably
fight back even while blind is obviously
because Dao is felt not seen with
someone's eyes as he cloaks himself in
it and allows him to feel up the
movements of his opponent and tells him
that they are utterly no match for him
standing there fully t-posed out of his
mind the immortal God re-welcomes them
to her eye causing Santa to fall into
despair upon not knowing what to do
against such a monster nearby siguri
tries to recover from mudan's earlier
attack stating that it was like it
affected a very Soul she pleads with
hoko to think back over all of the texts
he owns for anything that relates to a
possible weakness hoko though who was
obviously going through it realizing
that everything he's even known was a
lie says that he just he can't be
stopped since he has the powers of a God
and he's already accepted his passing
unable to just give up though siguri
encourages him to try and remember
anything and remind him of the fact that
they don't survive here then he'll never
see me again cutting in muda notes that
usual rehearse substitution technique
and other uses of Dao appear to have the
same attribute as him though this lifter
confused as to like what he was even
talking about not noticing sargeri
behind him obviously he considers taking
out Center but quickly catches on and
avoids the sneak attack having figured
out that he was using someone's intent
to figure out their next movements
sakuri throws his sword forth wondering
what an item without intent would do
Mudan I swear this like this man just
closed his eyes or something but this
dude just watches Esther Gary's blade
flies straight into his Tandon with Hoku
screaming at her to finish the job
security catches up to her blade and
Cleaves down pulling the blade through
the monster's Tandon the reason that the
attendant is such a vital spot to attack
throughout this series is because Dao is
born there then from there it Cycles
around somebody's body before returning
back to that point so on the case with
sargeri even if someone like tense and
takes damage in the Tandon it should
theoretically destroy them Over time
however Mooda reveals himself to be
perfectly fine explaining that attacks
without doubt do not harm him having
already come to that conclusion herself
so Gary thanks him as all she needed was
to get in close and confirm exactly how
it was activated taking a breath sigiri
releases a massive boost of Dao
completely confusing the immortal nerd
shocked by this phenomenon mudon leans
back just enough to avoid the lethal
swing try to think about what in the
world just happened Odin quickly comes
to the conclusion that sagiri can also
control Dao and gleefully Smiles two of
the stuff that's happened so far
throughout the series like her
experience with being near Gabby Morrow
and fighting Roku Rota siguri knows that
she's already able to perceive Dao or
she has to do now is and put a certain
amount of energy while controlling her
breathing patterns after learning that
sagiri's Dao can indeed harm him mood un
screams in Delight wondering if she'll
become another piece of beautiful art or
manage to kill him first placing his
hands together and using hojutsu Earth
year night Pilgrim he instantly vanishes
and appears before an unaware sagiri
attempting to attack her seen through
his trick usury are restrains mudon
using his strings and calls out to
sagiri saying that he's using a similar
ability to her substitution technique
seizing the opportunity sigiri tries to
take out mudon but the immortal uses the
sing Jutsu technique to release a burst
of Doubt from his mouth that afflict the
attack allowing him to kick her back
then with both girls somewhat occupied
commands the kiyoshi to attack usuryha
come in and clutch though scene to
quickly Cuts them down before taking a
distant down strike directly to the
chest thinking that the battle is going
smoothly for him Mudan taunts the group
letting them know that it's easy to read
their movements yet and that typical
think before you speak manga way of
doing things dude has his leg forcefully
detached by user rehard using a nympho
whip slash closing in the group
absolutely ravages The Immortal while he
simultaneously taunts them for just how
well they're doing quickly Escaping The
Mist before security strikes mudon
levitates up into the sky above them
using hojutsu earthyang Sky Pilgrim
speaking as if this dude's a God or
something it says to those ignorant of
the way of Dao would consider his
techniques to be divine having some
enlarged water droplets he then
activates sinjutsu tin splitter sending
all of them rocketing towards the ground
below cracking the very floor that
they're standing on with blood beginning
to fall from her nose scary notes just
as much of a stamina as being robbed by
the style remembering mudon's previous
statement about different types of Dao
user informed her that her down might be
the specific type that counters his
needing to force an opening for zagiri
to strike him down she steps forth and
uses that sticky string ability of hers
to bring the immortal closer after
withstanding a point-blank showering for
mudan's tin splitter she ropes the
creature towards the floor while
screaming out for sakiri to finish the
job reappearing himself the beaten
Ambrose Center seizes his chance to pin
him down allowing to carry a few more
moments to prepare her attack boasting
in siguri slices straight through the
Tandon of Mudan while implementing her
specific affinity for Dao finishing off
the supposedly Immortal creature
absolutely naked from the battle they
just endured both yusu riha and sigiri
quietly Rejoice after finally ending
their fight with mudon scary comes to
hoku's Aid and Recaps what she knows
about Dao the amount of Dao depends on a
specific individual and it can be
boosted or listened by manipulating one
spiritual intensity there are different
types of attributes Each of which can
give someone an advantage over the other
however the most important thing that
the group confirmed even if it
disappointed them was that the elixir of
Life didn't even exist not only form
that they suspected at least due to that
realization usury has stayed so they
would have to come up with another plan
but it's no use thinking on something
that they can't do anything about
looking over though she sees the massive
golden head statues and considers the
idea of replacing the elixir with a
massive amount of gold putting that
aside for now though the group just
decide to sit down and rest so Yuri sits
down with Santa and hears him give you
Zaria a compliment making her question
if he had any feelings for her Center
denies this and says that it's actually
he's more envious of user rehearse
innate Freedom during his childhood he
really wanted to become an artist but
for Generations the boys inside of his
family had been sent to train under the
Yamada Clan he couldn't deny or change
his future because it was tradition
though and Truth he hated it all the
idea of killing most of all struck a
note within him that led him to Sikh
religion and eventually become a scholar
and the end Center chose to abandon his
dream and carry out his duties as an
executioner he recalls how moments after
taking out Morrow yuzuria managed to see
right through him and how he admires the
way she seems so free feeling similar
about Gabby Morrow and how he's changed
over this Mission security brings up the
possibility that in the future all of
them could work together on the island
nearby user rihan notices that mudan's
body is continuing to turn into flowers
at a progressively alarming rate
instantly a stinger launches towards
usuryha taking her by surprise seemed to
though like the weeb king he is quickly
comes in shoving her out of the way but
sadly receiving a direct hit by the
plant falling into a hallucination it
shows seem to thinking about you's reha
while showing the beautiful artwork he
made of her deeply sinful was the way of
his work yet she was the Gale to
completely change the perception he had
about everything back in the prison the
effects of mudan's last ditch attack
caused flowers to instantly begin
sprouting from the head of Center
confirming his demise recent Pace books
answer absolute wee religion above him
though sargeria and usury are turn up to
watching horror as mudon starts to
transform into a monster before
completing his transformation as a
visual representation of Ian and yang At
Last At The flabbergasted humans knowing
that now are completely unable to do
anything against another attack ready in
itself achieves a plethora of similar
Stingers towards the girl however saving
the day the Blind King Yamada of Simon
Shion arrives on time and beautifully
Cuts The Stingers quickly acting hidden
orders and rugby to remove the growing
flowers from Santa's body and tell
siguri that he will stand in for the
fight against this creature after naruga
helps remove Santa's blooming flowers
scary asks hoko if there was a way to
save him unfortunately hoko states that
it was beyond his control either way she
helped Center by giving her medicine to
slow down the bleeding sargeria locks
towards Shion and asks about his current
condition but naruga informs her that
Shion is more than capable enough to
fight the monster and that they came
with the purpose of finding a certain
someone using the knowledge he acquired
from the experimentations on the Sochi
she opens off a bunch of these Stingers
before sprinting at the creature and
using fiend's flurry along with Autumn
Reigns to injure it not bothered mudan's
Chico form just annihilates the area by
creating more tin Splitters to rain down
from above throwing his sword for
through the smoke as a distraction then
appears himself and kicks the monster
across the courtyard however random
flowers start sprouting up all over
Sheeran due to the scratches he was
given by the monster Stingers without
even considering the damage that he
would take he removed him by slicing
away the stem of every flower on his
body despite the setback Sheen refuses
to give up stating that he has no Death
Wish yet if death lies in the coming
road then he'll accept it without
hesitation siguri tries to help Aiden
but the real guy stops her stating that
she can even barely walk herself let
alone fights regardless siguri explains
that she can allow Shion to sacrifice
himself for the lives of others however
if she does intervene then by working
together they could actually win hearing
this nuruga is persuaded to fight
alongside but use the rihar complains
that she just can't as she's too low on
energy walking over to them nuruga
randomly hugs both usuriha and sagiri
explaining it as this weird way to
restore stamina that she's been doing
from a very young age and now after
learning of Dao tried to implement it
differently able to move now because of
it sagario naruga really themselves to
step into the battlefield before doing
so though the jewer coat themselves and
bandages from user riha's protective
fluid as a way to prevent infection from
the monster Stingers then they both step
in a fight alongside Shion getting new
blind King's attention she informs him
that she knows the monster's weak point
so the plan to take him down will be
distracting the monster while he gets
him behind and takes out his Tandon
rushing at them linen attempts to take
out naruga first who somehow manages to
weave in and out of all of The Stingers
not seen his hand though mudon almost
manages to slam down on a real guy
however security manages to come in
clutch slashing at the hand and
defending herself from a secondary
Stinger attack rushing to get behind the
monster himself she on uses his Harvest
shell technique to create an opening but
it's just no use as the monster quickly
retaliates using a blast of Doubt
towards the samurai refusing to be
pushed back she on charges forth jumps
into the sky and Strikes down on the
creature yes this was all actually a
rose as he uses this moment to land on
the ground and strafe under the
monster's leg as it was still coming
down appearing behind its back now Shion
unleashes a flurry of slices that
seemingly cut through its branch-like
legs dropping it to the floor below now
it's somewhat of a similar High the
monster tries to defend itself but she
enforces himself through the attacks
while sargeria restrains one of its
hands with his sword allowing Shion to
get behind the Monster again thinking
about everything that has happened since
he made landfill she on becomes enraged
the fact that all he could do was flee
while his disciple was dying is
unforgivable for his own unforgivable
crimes of weakness he curses the gods
stating that until this foe's life ends
Yamada Simon Shion shunt no exoneration
this next technique of his took years to
craft thousands of lives made this
hidden technique so lethal for xion
manipulating these ways of Doubt as akin
to manipulate in his own life force and
spirit swinging his blade down now he
threatens these false gods telling them
that it's time they learned about the
fleeting nature of a normal life it's
Beauty and Terror she on swings this
blade down towards the monster's Tandon
but holds himself after not sensing any
strong waves making himself wonder if
those were even its weak points which is
massive after the like the just the
whole speech he went through before that
knowing that he doesn't have time to
overthink the central situation Center
the goat arises From the Ashes for a
moment to scream out that the monster's
weakness is its ovule since its body is
plant-based guiding him to exactly where
the ovule is located on the creature she
on Dives forth dodgingly regenerated
stingers and slashing at the weak spot
causing multiple mood on heads to begin
sprouting out one of the hits becomes
captivated by xi'an's unwavering ability
to face death stating that it truly
achieved Bliss Yin and Yang in Perfect
Harmony slashing at the open weak spot
now xion finally manages to take down
mudon sending the massive creature he
formed crashing onto the ground below
with it beginning to dissipate now the
surrounding area becomes covered in
beautiful looking flowers
after finally ending the battle scary
rushes over to Center who's still like
somehow alive at this point but really
succumbing to his wounds scary bigs use
rihad to apply more of her medicine to
him however she refuses as it just
wouldn't make sense to use the Romanian
amount she has left on Center when he's
guaranteed to die instead she's more of
a realist and understands It Center
knows he's at the end of his road so it
only makes sense to give the rest to
xiong use a riha comfort center as she
tells him to let go of his duties as an
executioner and think about something
that he truly desires as his last
memories crouching down the side Center
and his final moments she tells him to
think about something else instead of
his honor bound staff think about
something that he holds dear like a
family pit or a lover he won't ever see
again and if it helps she'll hold him
close in these dark times slowly passing
away now Santa just thinks about the few
small Joys he had in life and now the
beautiful user riha next to him as he
dies with a smile on his face
and a moment of silence the group buries
his body and decides to rest before
continuing on the journey scary thanks
to zariha and the ruga for their help
but states that from now on she will not
suffer the death of another Ally all of
them will survive and escape this island
no matter what elsewhere and after
waking up from his unconscious State
gabimaru instinctively jumps from where
he was to see against your side fuchi
and Mei or just chilling out staring at
him Fuji informs him that they're
situated in a cave halfway up the valley
and are just stopping for the night
Kevin Murray thinks to himself that he
can't seem to remember all of the
details to how he fell unconscious with
them awake now though she begins going
over what they know so far about Dao
meanwhile siguri's group into harai and
settle inside one of the buildings to
also go over what they know so far yusu
riha and urugai happily use the
opportunity to change into some like
Chinese looking clothing while she on
tries to discuss what they know about
Dao he explains that an infused doubt
wisely or there will be grave
consequences for their body mine and in
the worst cases even death remembering
what Hoka had told him Shion brings up
the idea that multiple types of waves or
Dow actually exist in his eyes there
would have to be wood fire earth metal
and water these five attributes are
locked into a weave of constant
influence some types would help to heal
or restore someone's dowel whereas
others would do the opposite and hinder
someone's to a greater extent she
unbelieves that if they can exploit
these attributes or types then maybe
even the Immortals might be failed the
rule guy then reminds him that they need
to also focus on acquiring the elixir of
Life watch from what we know doesn't
exactly exist in fruit-like form usury
has states that from like what Mudan had
said about the electro during the early
stages of their fight it's not actually
what they're looking for however
according to Kevin marrow his village
Chief is Immortal because of an Elixir
which proves that something must exist
binakunuichi though yusu rihad just
knows how these Villages work behind the
scenes and explains the possibilities of
the chief using an illusion no one is
genjutsu to try and fool his people into
thinking that he was an immortal in
order for them to bend towards Authority
meanwhile Fuji interprets Mae's words
and explains to them that the proper use
of certain attributes will help them
defeat the enemy while listening
gabbymara wonders if he has some kind of
Amnesia or mind blank as he's still
unable to recall anything from the past
with this in mind and at the same time
yusu riha explains her theory that Gabby
maro's wife might also be an illusion
set up by the clan in order for Gabby
Mario to have a purpose in surviving his
missions siguri stands there shocked
unable to reply while over there in the
cave give him our confirms that he can't
remember anything once more he knows
that he is Gaby Mario the hollow the
strongest Shinobi in iwakahure but
because his memory is fragmented decides
to currently go along with what's
happening until he can determine whether
the people around him are allies or hide
in their true nature having finished
discussing what they know about Dao
though she decides that they should get
some rest for now and move off tomorrow
later on as the others sleep May walks
outside to check up on Gabby who tells
her he's okay but may becomes shocked
after seeing that half of his doubt is
completely gone at the same time inside
of her eye scary sets outside until
she's also joined by Shion the two jerk
around for a moment but Sakira can't
help to think about all of her Fallen it
what could have possibly happened to
Gabi Maru after hearing her concern
Shion asked if security had feelings for
Gabby Morrow however she stops him
Midway and denies his allegations
nevertheless she explains that she feels
sorry for Gabby Morrow he was born into
a murderous Village and his past still
haunts him plus what's even worse is the
fact that if you use a riha is correct
about his wife not even existing then
his motivation for surviving this
mission was a complete fast siguri
apologizes to xion for spewing out all
of her thoughts onto him however xion
explains that he understands what she
was talking about and says that he can
overlook this matter causing security to
laugh at his pun you know like obviously
because our men's blind and everything
the next day though Gabby Morris group
then leave the cave and travel up the
rest of the valley before encountering
the brothers chobe and Toma hearing Fuji
say they're more humans might mean more
friends chubby smiles and spin kicks
Gabby Maru back on demon time Gabby
vanishes from in front of chobe lands on
his shoulders and simulate takes him out
in one swift move however May screams
out warning him that chobi's Dao is
massive randomly grabbing a hold of him
probably stands back up and rips Gabby
into the ground telling them that he
isn't interested in becoming allies
elsewhere and after having left the
mainland now Lord Aoki finds it foolish
that the Shogun is planned to send off
around 50 iwakari ninja believing that
their leader has motives of his own
sugar tries to calm the Lord down
assuming that his concern is what the
multiple Ninja on board randomly though
a good questions of him and the other
three esomen were capable of controlling
these ninjas since two of them seemed to
be unranked yo so uh rolling up to the
island along with Rank 4 Chica and the
EG eyes and standing as the little man
kiromaru and the Beautiful but still
unmatched Isuzu the little man himself
Keo he isn't ranked because the man is
still young to actually take part in
this system and Isuzu isn't as well
because she takes the role as a combat
instructor employed personally by the
Shogun shugen states that they don't
just approach this Mission as mere
observers no the whole purpose for the
expedition to the island is to back up
and support the Vanguard hiramaru who's
just like obviously listening to all of
this becomes annoyed with Aoki as he
thinks it's pathetic some random old
fart can judge him because they're
unranked when a little reality he could
probably take him out before the dude
even knows what happened to him Isuzu
tries to stop him but kyoma reflexes the
fact that he could literally take down
everyone on the ship alone and cuts the
mask of the Ninja that appears next to
him furious with kiramari's rude
Behavior Isuzu draws who played placing
it near his neck and demanded that his
sheaths his sword were the two
exchanging cochlears at each other
another random iwaku crying ninja tells
them that they mustn't worry about them
at all noticing him she awkwardly
apologizes to the male ninja but he
continues to assure her that he didn't
mind and if they still had doubts than
to pick any one of them then that's his
chosen one will be thrown overboard to
show their loyalty intrigued he oh
hilariously tests his loyalty by
choosing a ninja who spoke up as the one
to take himself out crazily enough it's
shown that they dude was the leader of
the airwanger curry Squad and before
following through with what he promised
passed on the leadership to the ninja
next to him following through with the
order now he takes himself out proving
the Loyalty their squad commands crazily
enough like I didn't actually say it
while he was passing away there but he
might as a children's before passing
away which is called the toyansi it's a
tune that accompanies a childhood game
similar to like London bridges falling
down when you're in the pool and you go
into the water type thing and funnily
enough it's still often used on the
modern day crosswalks as they choose to
let people know when it is and when it
isn't safe to cross When the Music Stops
obviously the game is over and it was
representative of like the tune the dude
sung I thought it was quite a poetic
Yuki right there anyway continuing on
having gained leadership the other ninja
speaks up saying that the only desire to
exist is tools and pleads for their
trust at that moment one of the other
evil ninjas walks over to his former
boss and remembers the orders given to
them by the chief infiltrate this
Mission and kill Gabi Maru ensure that
he has purged from this world even if
you have to sacrifice yourselves for the
cause over on the other side of the bow
kiramaru discusses the validity of like
what's just going on with Shogun calling
them all just random weirdos shugen
agrees explaining that it doesn't matter
as he's never like trusted them to begin
with all he's ever seen them is is
criminals they themselves alone are
enough to find the solicitor of life
becoming enraged with the thought of
losing even more loved ones shugan state
has resolved to have every Criminal on
the island executed so as clan members
can return home Kiera throws out the
possibility of already all of them being
failed yet after receiving a vicious
glare Sprints off I always laugh at this
as well but sugar hopes that Eisen has
big man the rank number one and that
everyone else is still safe on the
island meanwhile chica questions Aoki of
bringing in all of these Shady dudes was
going to make the mission more difficult
again it's reiterated that it's the
shogun's plans to make a swift
resolution and he thinks Eddie Vanguard
will be overjoyed by the upcoming
arrival however chicken knows the
reality of the situation this ship isn't
the bringer of Hope no only chaos and
death the personification of a vessel
equipped with people to drive them to
hell even faster the stuff of nightmares
with this in mind tries one last
time to get him to have the ship to
return home however it's obviously to
like no use honestly I really really
like jika his characters too cool and
he's really really mysterious kind of
reminds me the old OG San at this point
in the series or similar characters
either way like there are just so many
amazing lines in the story that are
almost artistic with the way that they
spark some sort of vivid image in your
head both xiaomi was like trying to fail
mood on and both here with jika are
prime examples I think it plays into the
whole time period that Japan is in
throughout the series that's one we're
like art and language flourished and I
think it's perfectly adapted into the
story in its own kind of like subtle way
with like sin to passing away for
example and how like you got to see his
own artistic representation of what user
rehab would have looked like just really
cool I don't know moving forward
floating there as he rebounds back off
the ground Gabby Morrow knows that Jobe
just healed a fatal wound and figures
that he's most likely also one of those
Immortals Gabby shoots a kick towards
chobe but it's comfortably blocked
having a hold of his League now the
criminal then fling scare me over and
smashes them into the ground below as if
he had some sort of like superhuman
strength Debbie Mara who's still
tripping at this point focuses his mind
on trying to take out chobe his scream
so he's going to tear him to Paces
before pulling up his mask and
activating nympho blooming needle
shooting at him Rock straight towards
his opponent Trevor manages to dodge but
Gabi Mario uses the previous attack as a
distraction to quickly get above his
Target a mortal or not can be flawlessly
assumed that if he targets the brang and
other senses then it should allow him to
get the other hand however as we've
learned so far when someone can
manipulate Dao that that just won't work
instead chubby kicks Gabby in the head
knowing exactly where he was just off
presence alone Gabby Marathon bites at
him as a last-ditch effort which
completely throws Trevi off jumping back
he wonders as to why he's acting so
uncivilized while at the same time Gabby
still on the animal Vibe tries to bite
his opponent in vital areas managing to
get on his shoulders Gabby tries to bite
down once more but is unable to do any
damage as Chubby's wounds are instantly
healed standing opposite each other now
chubby steps it up a notch and Stomps
the ground causing the area to break
apart leaving Gabby open to a free hit
as he struggles with his footing Toby
Collins the Gabi Morrow is weak and uses
his doubt to strike him standing nearby
and having watched the entire battle so
far get into your side wonders why Gabi
Maru is fighting poorly in comparison to
his last battle and asks May if she has
any idea being able to see Dao clearly
May knows that Gabby's energy is lacking
his form and he lost something extremely
important to him but due to her
inability to communicate properly the
others can't follow what she's saying
beginning to take a fair amount of
damage now Tropicals out to Tomah to
attack the others listening to his
Broski Homer flies forth and goes after
genticho Sai assuming that because he
had lost his hand he's easy taking to my
against exercise the dragon utterly
perplexed by this person's choice to
attack him first catches his sword and
hit butts Tomah while stealing his blade
in the process insulted with the thought
that a kid could take him out he throws
the former Simon's blade down telling
them to get ready for the real battle in
coma's mind he only sees himself as an
extension of his older brother and his
brother decides the order of things
screaming at the Doshi Tomo then gets it
to join the battle commanding it to
attack these smaller ones but fucci who
stole with May steps in to guard her
back in the other bake down and seeing
as how he was being overpowered gabimaru
ignites his body and solely focuses on
destroying chobe he knows that when on
the verge of death a Shinobi can wreak
Untold levels of Destruction upon their
enemy now completely Ablaze he Sprints
towards the immortal criminal and uses
nympho Burning Bridge in combination
with an impostoned storm to see a bunch
of hated rocks flying through chobay
crashing to the ground Gabby Mario gets
on top of him prepared to send himself
and chobe to the shadow realm the
criminal tries saying that they'll both
perish if he continues but Gabby
literally doesn't care he doesn't even
know why he's on his random island or
partaking in this mission to begin with
if he dies right now it's not like it'll
even matter his village will just send
another person to take his place as at
the end of the day Shinobi are just a
hive with nothing to lose and those who
cling to life will never win hearing
this and becoming enraged with the idea
that he can't win because he has an
attachment to his brother Toby thanks
gabimaru for helping him realize his
resolve so remember Mei and like the
strong weak stuff from earlier on well
as Toby states to himself that he does
indeed have something to lose his mind
becomes weaker and his body begins to
transform into his breakdown State
remember how I brought up earlier in the
video that kashikai literally means like
demon corpse undo or something like that
this literally here is I guess Cho Bay's
version of the kishikai form with his
breakdown State literally telling his
body to come apart or break down anyway
moving forward I just love how this form
is called a breakdown because oh my Lord
these boys about to dance having
unlocked this new form Toby unleashes a
transformation and uncontrollably
attacks give me Maru Gabby tries to Ward
him off by releasing a large burst of
flames using limpo burning brooch but
it's no use as the demon slashes his way
through them unable to block in time Big
C seems a bunch of tentacles shooting
through the hollow allowing him to toss
Gabby across the entire area activating
nympho ascetic Blaze Gabby just barely
manages to detach himself from the vines
unable to see anymore chobi's
Consciousness begins to be consumed by
the darkness causing him to slash out an
anger wondering where in the world did
Ninja could have gone with the other
groups no longer fighting gintuchusai
wonders why Gabby isn't using Dao to
fight like he did yesterday May who
knows what's coming on obviously says
that he is unable to use Dao and can't
win against chobe as the man is just too
strong falling into a moment of deep
thought Debbie Morrow makes the
conscious decision to use up his
remaining Life Force to kill chobe
however he has briefly stopped by a
vision of someone long forgotten
ignoring this uneasiness he rushes
towards chobe really to do whatever it
takes watching these beasts become more
and more confused but she just knows
that both of them have completely lost
themselves turning and seeing his
brother become more Beast than man Tomah
remembers getting teacher's size words
from earlier and realizes that Toby has
been fighting for his sake back in the
battle chobe continues on his Rampage
sadly though he soon comes to say that
for the past few blows as he wondered
what he was he unknowingly attacked his
brother Tomer who would just try to make
him come back to his senses stuck and
unable to move taking in what he'd just
done Toma tries to break through to his
brother's shell telling him that he's
everything in the world to him sadly as
he was doing this though Gabby Morrow
saw the perfect opportunity to deal the
finishing blow and prepare himself to do
so not wanting Gabby to burn away the
last of his doubt because he'll die May
rushes in to stop him from doing
anything else standing behind him she
releases is a massive Blast from her Dow
creating a crater that causes Gabby Mo
and the two siblings to start falling
Kevin Morrow manages to get himself to
safety and as chobe turns to look for an
Escape Route throw stones forcing him
deeper into the hole thinking quickly
chobi uses his Vines to throw Tomah to
safety while telling him to wait for his
return so remember how ganti Josiah and
Fuji don't really know may yet like this
ain't the Hoku group from before and
seeing who use this level of Doubt makes
them question just how she accomplished
such a feat and an even more surprising
Revelation for the two as shown that may
was now fully growing meanwhile inside
of her eye siguri suggests that they go
outside and reunite with gamimaru and
the others however yusu rear doesn't
agree and instead thinks their focus
should be on trying to escape from the
island Co sees through her intentions of
wanting to save herself and reveals her
own plan to return home safely with
every remaining person as them that way
they have an alibi siguri reassures her
that her desire to escape hasn't changed
it's just that everyone will be leaving
this place together switching the
conversation up she Ponders managed to
arrive at the gate from the very
beginning to watch usual reho reveals
that he definitely did as she found
evidence that he was here before they
came in her eyes their best bet to bump
back into Gabby marrow now is to
actually wait around their gate after
deciding to head over to the gate the
girls know that seeing her eye clearly
during the day is absolutely insane
looking around The Godly City the group
becomes captivated by its Mystic Aura
Hoka remembers mudan's words about law
tense and experimenting with humans
lives and the humans on the island
acting as test subjects curiously he
asks himself if the current humans on
the island will bring a change after
seeing that they've managed to take out
an immortal and wonders if he will still
be alive when they do so once they reach
the gate the group in counterfeuchi
gangtitsusai May Toma and an unconscious
Gabi Maru after the initial surprise of
everyone noticing each other both of
Kerry and Fuji asked what happened in
their time apart after noticing that may
was still okay and had matured after
using her power Fuji expresses his
gratitude that her allies kept her safe
confused on how they even arrived here
Hoku asked if they came up from the
social first and after learning that
they did Hoku can only think that
throughout the thousand years he's lived
no one had managed to accomplish these
Fates and because of their beliefs that
the current Travelers are humans Beyond
Compare after being informed of his
boy's passing Fuji stands next to
Center's grave and cries in sorrow after
confirming the deaths of most groups and
seeing the remaining survivors Shion
expresses to create that so little have
survived the ordeal on the island
however gent hits his eye comments that
his feeling of regret was wasted on the
condemned criminals since they were
fated to kill each other the moment
everyone made landfall unlike Shion
thought hilsu states that thinking all
your comrades would survive as
ridiculous he then points towards Tomah
since it's like obvious that it was a
traitor and offers to get rid of him not
wanting him too though Gary steps in to
stop him as without chobe around as well
he really doesn't pose a threat at all
use a reho is just being Chill on there
this whole time interrupts and has
everyone around Focus their attention
towards Gary marrow's injuries stating
that the dudes literally knocking on
death's door rolling up though she
elaborates on what happened before they
got here and how he expanded far too
much Dow he did what he did when he came
to killing him but because the injuries
got Beyond physical he wasn't able to do
much kneeling down and looking at her
injured friend scary watches as gave me
my reawakens and instantly tries to
stand up siguri says that they should
look into his wounds but Gabby Mario's
shrugs her off while saying he's fine
June warns him that without proper
treatment he will die but Gabby claims
that he's already accepted this fact
stunned with hearing the old Gabby again
scary just questions who he is looking
at her Gabby answers that she already
knows who he was he's Gabby Maru the
hollow launching himself forward Gabby
Mario attacks Aguirre luckily for her
though big Fuji and she unnoticed what
he was up to and blocked the strike
knowing that the disturbance and one's
doubt can affect memory siguri explains
that Gabby Morrow has lost all of his
memories due to every battle he's fought
wearing away at the construction of his
very Soul siguri tries to raise him with
a confused friend explaining that she is
truly an ally and just wants to help him
after he repeatedly tries pushing her
away siguri becomes enraged and uses
Force to pin him down Genji took her
watches thinking they're doing like
sneaky bochujitsu was stunning though
fochi doubts this one may blush is
saying that this act was different yet
similar in some fact which you know what
do you mean by I'm confused scary on top
of Gabby explains how they don't really
have times for Such trivial activities
but they need his strength to escape
this island so in an attempt to wake him
up even quicker she reminds Gabby that
he has someone to return home to then
finally in that exact same moment
gemimaru's doubt is restored and his
memories began flooding back in which is
really confusing like I I always get
confused on how he managed to gain his
memories back there but it gets revealed
later on so don't you worry so uh
throwback boys and girls remember after
the crater incident that happened
earlier well after reaching the very
bottom of the valley and regenerating
his limbs Toby reflects on his actions
during the fight with Gabby Maru looking
at just how far down he'd fell dude
literally cracks the code and figures
out that the island is shaped like a
bowl with ridges connecting the middle
part and then spots a group of Social
and decides to use them to test out his
applications of Dao meanwhile all of the
remaining survivors relocate to a cave
that gets cases I found to remove
themselves from low tense and sensory
ability that he has over her eye this is
just due to the fact that their leader
who is rein if you haven't kind of
figured out by this point can sense
where they are at all times using the
dowel in the ear remember like how there
was a high level of humidity to the
island hiding it to start with well it's
my thought as well that he uses these
abilities to hide the island while
bringing it in a select few to turn into
tan I'd love to know like what you guys
think on that down below though so of
course let me know I'll take into your
site called she on a coward because he
was scared of Lord tencent and warned
everyone to be cautious he receives
judgment from user riha and naruga who
also reiterates just how dangerous they
are having regained his memory she even
asked Gabby Mario if he had fought one
as well and he confirms her he also
confirms to them that he knows how to
manipulate down now but Wings about
learning it the hard way along with
finding out just how terrifying Lord
tencent really was having told his
experience yuzuriha gives her opinion
that it would be best for them to escape
the island but Gabby Mario objects as he
knows that without the pardon he'll
never Escape hearing this yuzuriha goes
to tell him about her Theory but he shot
Gabby cutter off knowing that she was
going to say his wife was just a form of
ginjutsu he tries just pushing past what
she said but usually riha wants to make
sure she's not walking into a trap oh
boy he knows she exists though as he can
tell just based on the sensation he has
when he thinks about her wanting to know
more info that isn't just like sensation
based as it's not very logical of him to
think that a sensation is real Kevin
Murrow describes the little things he
can remember about her like her voice or
the shape of her eyes and says that even
now on beautiful days like this when his
drenched in nature he can sense her
nearby phasing into a blissful memory he
reveals her name as yui which I hope I
said right saying that this was the only
proof he had the only way to be sure was
to make it home and find out if she was
actually real his confidence causes
sakiri to feel delighted and gets
hitusai who calls her boy a man's man to
feel like he finally found a perfect
fighting partner I actually love gented
to say such a damn cool character
uzoriha though found it weird that a
Shinobi like Gabby Mario can talk about
his weaknesses but she on adds in the
fact that he could sense Gaby Morrow's
Dow growing which approach to him that
his wife is real and people who have
something to lose are considered
extremely strong which is just like a
chobe for example with him not wanting
to lose his brother so uh funnily enough
and continuing with the possible idea
that she doesn't actually exist Joey
doesn't really confirm that it is a
person the kanji he used through a name
simply means Bond or connection and it
is the first part of how you'd spell out
like marriage in Japanese so does she
truly exist or is she a manifestation
made up by the chief of the clan I'd
love to know your thoughts and all of it
down below before we get to the end of
the series and obviously if if you've
read the series then you know like let
me know her thoughts on the series down
below back down in the valley though and
after Merck and every single showing
around chobe is met by Rhian who
questions if he was the one who took out
Mudan elsewhere Fuji feeling unlike nomu
to examine the Doshi after finding out
about the death of his comrades decides
to set him free over inside the cave now
sargerian forms Fuji that may is feeling
ill and hasn't been able to recover any
of his strength so would you be able to
make us medicine annoyed though after
finding out that she's the same as Lord
tensen Fuji Grace to hell but demands it
in return may tell them everything they
need to know about herself and Lord
tensin meanwhile getting married sits
outside and makes a request to the other
four to help him train to utilize Dao
even more efficiently super eager to
learn more himself Thomas starts off by
attacking multiple entitsu's size sword
dodging The slashes Gabby focuses on
sensing the movements of his opponent's
doubt not tracking with his eyes big G
then comes in and makes his attack on
Gabby but he easily uses his Dow to
sense the strike weaving out of the way
and allowing him to examine gantees to
size weak spots hidden kicks off the
doubt in this guy to put some space
between him and the group noodle guy
jumps in and tries attacking however
Gabby grabs her and uses her to push
back the others as they approach as the
battle continues Gabi marrow believes
that it's pointless to try and hone more
refined techniques than the Immortals
since they've been training for over a
thousand years instead the key to
defeating Lord tensin is to use their
own Dow against them standing back up
naruga approaches Gabby believing that
he was more than capable enough to take
down lord tense in however gibbimaru
believes that he still needs more time
to improve Big Gig and his desire asks
if he's finished with the warm-up though
because man's Keen to get serious before
randomly diving forth raging out and
preparing to strike down on Gabby while
the other two start freaking out
thinking they're actually probably
battling back inside Decay Fuji explains
to sagari and user riha they're the
island the monsters and Lord tension
were created by a singular entity this
being is apparently a famed Hoshi who
used sinshan principles in his attempt
to research ways to achieve immortality
for those confused on what Hoshi is
pretty much it's an ancient Chinese
Mystic versed in divination and other
Healing Arts this particular Mystic
developed methods to Tinker with Dow
directly from this he created
crossbreeds of creatures that had
similar affinities for Dao then after an
age of creation Lord tensin was finally
born this being as a fusion of human
implant Dao that is both male and female
both yin and yang hence how they can
change genders in an instant gender
Benders life forms usually use doubt
over the course of their life but the
Lord tencen's energy has been polished
for over a thousand years far beyond the
scope of human ability use a riha like
who's obviously confused over why
they're even here asks what they're
purpose for living on the island was
then Fuji explains that the tencents
have been practicing taoism or more
specifically the inner ways of tan which
is meditation and the outer ways of tan
which is making the election to achieve
immortality hearing this user rehire
insecuri become shocked realizing that
the elixir does indeed exist yet Fuji
tells him that it's probably just a
prototype a potion created from
harvesting and extracting the Dao of
humans in order to expand attention's
lives knowing this Fuji tells him that
it's possible to take out Lord tencent
if their doubt is depleted curious after
learning this usually have questions
while they are going further with their
research since they have already created
tan Mayans is saying that it was
possible that Lord tington was following
The Well of their Master zhufu Fuji
explains that zhufu also known as Joe
fuku in Japan was a Hoshi Mystic and
served the emperor of the shin Dynasty
whose journeyed off to research the
secret of immortality a thousand years
ago but eventually came to an end once
he entered Japan perhaps though he never
really came to an end and instead lives
on as someone to this very day hmm I
want to know who like your thoughts at
this exact moment on who you possibly
think that this person could be it's
given us this image of this dank looking
foot so surely that hence the someone of
great age who is still indeed alive so
this jifu or Joe fuku person like
obviously just revealed before as
actually a real man from way back in the
3rd Century BCE and as I mentioned
earlier in the video he was sent out to
search for this mythical mountain and
the elixir of life he oversaw a fleet of
60 vessels and thousands of crew members
Artisans and civilians and 219 BC he
actually made it back after the first
voyage having unsuccessfully found the
Elixir or ping lie yet after hitting out
nine years later and 210 BCE he never
returned some people suggested he ended
up making landfall near like Mount Fuji
however and house Paradise it's obvious
that the man's Voyage ended only sees
Southwest of Japan while the girls in
Fuji discussed the Joe fuku's existence
May falls back exhausted also revealing
that her left had turned into a branch
she explains that her usage of Doubt is
causing her body to turn into a tree and
she needs to take an energy in order to
heal usury has suggests using a
restoration technique however may say
that it won't work since she has little
doubt already and because Rand broke her
tendon causing it to constantly leak out
after the cruel past May went through it
was showing to us hoco then like the
champion he is offered his doubt to
fully heal her due to how Lord tension
can extract Dao from living life forms
it's the only way for Mei to actually
heal herself but obviously she's
hesitant to sacrifice hoco big Bonsai
though insists as soon he'll go through
the process of amplification anyway to
him this is one way he can also atone
for his sins explaining that he ignored
maester's eyes of wanting to leave the
island and instead choosing to raise her
as a replacement to his deceased
daughter Mae tearfully tells hoko that
from the time he found her she always
thought of him just like a father she
then accepts his offer placing out her
hand and absorbing his Dow with hoku's
energy flowing into may she gives him
her final farewell before returning back
to her young estate meanwhile the
previously raging battle has come to a
peaceful end obviously you know I
remember how against Josiah and Gabby
went at it just before we skipped away
well yeah she own is left impressed with
Gabriel's abilities and believes that he
may have what it takes to defeat Lord
tense in Tomah then randomly drops down
on his knees and big scientists decide
to help train him how to wield a sword
so that he can gain the power to escape
the island himself Big G doesn't believe
that he can trust him just yet but in a
show of Honor Toma then cuts his hair
and asks once again to help make him
strong impressed with a little guy's
determination game teachers agrees with
helping Tomah and tells him to come
follow him back down in the social
Valley Jobe notices that the thing in
front of him had the exact same face as
the creature he fought earlier
fascinated with the hybridization chobi
had achieved Rhian explains that they
create the watan Hua flower that
converts human bodies into tan yet
somehow even as the root of that plan
dug into trouble's Dao he still keep his
sense of self wanted to examine him
further Rhian attacks chobe with an
attack similar to 10 causing him to
quickly Dodge while realizing that he
has no chance in winning this battle in
an attempt to fight back he transforms
into his breakdown State and dashes Adam
before letting loose a flurry of strikes
and states that Rangers barely managed
to block somehow Toby actually manages
to overwhelm Rianne but finds it
difficult to keep the vines inside of
his mind from taking over his true body
after piercing Ryan's Tandon Toby
expands his Vines and destroys the
immortal's body assuring to him that
Luke tandem was indeed the correct place
to take out these creatures however and
really randomly Rhian then suddenly
appears behind chobe again revealing
that he destroyed only one of his many
clones that he brought along with him
after seeing chubby unleash Dao from the
watan Hua flower Brian expresses his
satisfication at the fact he managed to
control her and decides to take him back
to the Palace trouble tries to attack
but is unable to resist the effects of
the vines allowing Rhian to bend down in
front of him and use a dow strike to
knock him unconscious slowly falling
into a dream he reiterates his desire of
not making the same mistake as his
father by abandoning his brother later
chubby wakes up in a beard and sees is a
female standing nearby tending the
plants Ren explains that she finds chobe
to be the final key to completing her
research and wishes to understand his
Dow cycle better through bochujutsu yeah
but you know we can't actually go there
so just know that your man is the key to
unlocking the perfect being sadly there
is like so much I can't actually go over
in this part of the story but pretty
much because chobe is revealed to be the
perfect Bane in this case I guess you
could say when his Dow is extracted then
it will allow these creatures to turn
everyone on the mainland of Japan into
tan so yeah that's I guess the big evil
plan that's in store for our main crew
something else I also wanted to mention
was that the kanji and watan Hua
translates to outside tan and flower
meaning a flower used for the outer way
of tan literally anyways later on in the
day I'll cheat again teacher's side
breaks down crying and pain that may had
reverted back to her child body in his
eyes it was way more comfortable
carrying her around when she was older
actual chair though ain't none of that
weird stuff that's why I like against
his eye he's a he's a champ in my eyes
by the way back with the main group she
on in collaboration with Gabby prepares
to announce the next plan however May
catches their attention when she senses
that the second Landing party has
arrived on the island she knows that it
isn't Lord tension but due to how she
can't articulate herself well says that
their Dao is very strong having taught
this man xion believes that it's most
likely shugen and the other Reserva
Simon who was sent as reinforcements by
the Shogun art Fuji also tells them that
another group of criminals were to
accompany them as well curious Gabby us
sagiri ashugin as a potential ally and
she vouches for him saying that he might
even be the strongest amongst them
however gen teacherside doubts his
statement knowing that he'll need more
than just strength to survive here thank
you back on the past Shion confirms that
shugen is already able to perceive Dao
since it was actually home to First
notice the six sins and call them waves
over at the coast sugar hands off his
blade and confronts a shoshin obviously
man's yolked up already able to perceive
the environment around him through the
use of Dao alone the monster somehow
manages to grab him but through what he
learned while training with Shion shugan
easily lift the monster's hands from his
shoulders and defeats it be a-handed
back with our main Squad naruga is
impressed with the idea of how strong
shugen is however yuzuriha mentions a
certain story that made him Infamous
siguri explains his story of how shuga
took out all of the caption members in
front of their leader in order to reveal
the remaining hidden members after he
revealed their location they too were
all arrested and well yeah you can
imagine definitely what happened next
hence how he gets the the Anakin
nameless those poor kids his Shogun was
so impressed by his brutality that he
presented the young assignment with a
ceremonial outfit and a named Blade the
furubutsu kaneki the group becomes
concerned but sigiri reassures them that
deep down he's a great guy leading Fuji
to state that shugen was sakiri's first
crush she says that even if that was the
case she merely admired his involvement
in her earning a ranking in the Yamada
Clan back over with a sneaky man and
after taking out a group of social Isuzu
and kiyumaru come to his aid but Shogun
reassures them that as their senior he
will take responsibility on taking care
of the Lesser matters like fighting the
pathetic monsters while security
believes that shugen will come to their
aid Shion disagrees and reveals the full
story of how sugar not only murked the
entire silver serpent group but also
their loved ones since they might hold
some form of Vengeance towards the
Shogun she unexplains that shugen
despises criminals and would not think
of allying with him or have anyone he
Associates work with him at all as the
new grip at the shore begins traveling
shooking stumbles across his sight where
Eisen was turned into a pancake by Roku
Rota after both of his parents were
taken out by an Infamous Bandit shuken
was dropped to the door of the Yamada
Clan obviously in a flashback and as the
two begin talking about what it means to
be an executioner shugan tells Eisen
that he fails to see the logic and their
clean's way of executing criminals and
wonders why they can't give them a
painful death instead Eisen explains
that such an act would defile the
execution grounds and the chipping of
his blade would be meaningless being an
Esserman means ridding yourself of that
hatred and he'll hone him into a great
man hidden tells him that he looks
forward to the day he becomes a glorious
blade in the present shukin screams and
pain over eisen's death and instead of
moving forward with the mission makes a
decision to lay his soul to rest while
giving him a proper burial one of the
Ninja thinks to himself that three of
these people are extremely odd and Jake
is just as random himself with a
priority for them being Gabi marrow they
all plan on using the dangers of the
island to outsmart the Samurai and
complete their mission out of freaking
nowhere though a massive flower type
thing drops down on the 50 or so ninja
catching a few of them looking up the
group see a bunch of mon chin rolling up
and trying to capture them commanded by
Doshi another massive flower thing drops
down on the trio but Keo and Isuzu
quickly cut it to shreds while shug and
sat there unmoved still mourning eisen's
passing so the ninja also dispatched two
squads of Ganon to assist in bringing
down the monshin after finishing his
sutras shugen finally says Eisen can
rest in peace not even standing yet
sugarness swiftly draws his blade and
cuts down a monsoon that attempted to
attack him from behind angered with
everything that he's saying Shogun
smashes his brand new named blade
against the monster staff to repeatedly
damage it standing there and bleeding
from the eyes with rage he swears
Vengeance against all that reside on the
island hearing shugen to clearing his
wrath to him the Doshi prepares to
attack him with thou however the fight
quickly comes to an end which you can
utterly obliterating and stopping him
from regenerating he then starts to do
some really questionable acts Jake Hill
Lake obviously gets him to stop and
tries to raise him with shugen and
returning to the mainland with the
information they've gathered so far but
is angrily told that that's not gonna
happen he didn't ask Jacob why he hadn't
drawn his blade yet leading the old dude
to state that he can't even still sugar
knows for a fact that he can making him
get even more Furious cutting in on the
boy Isuzu tells him to calm down making
him realize the stupidity of his ways
quickly changing his demeanor shugen
apologizes to chica but States at his
earlier statement of eliminating
everything on the island was true so
don't forget that hearing this one of
the Ninja recommends that they should
handle everything in regards to
collecting information sensing ninja has
special tactics in their area meanwhile
I'm back with our main Squad the
survivors of the Vanguard party listen
to xion's plan of separating everyone
into two groups where one finds an
Escape Route and the other finds the
Tanner lecture after gen teachers asks
how exactly they're going to fight Lord
tensen she on repositions everyone and
creates a diagram on the ground of the
Dow attributes that each of them possess
the idea is that they will use the
attributes to hinder each member of Lord
tensin and defeat them yusu rihad though
believes that it's hopeless to continue
due to the risks and not knowing who
they are begins at the coast of the
island she then suggests an alternative
Way by finding a way off the island and
instead going into hiding as a way to
possibly survive Shion understands where
yusu riha is coming from and knows that
there are honestly just too many
unknowns in the coming future so because
of this he takes everyone's thoughts on
The Meta into consideration by giving
them the option of going their own
separate ways or working together and
surviving after walking into the cave
Shion immediately senses the presence of
every single person behind him deciding
to move forward with his plan due to
their own personal reasons and surviving
with this situation growing more dire
she owners at least relieved that they
all came to the same decision and tells
them him that they are all each other's
last chance of survival
boom so that there officially brings us
to the very end of what is the Lord
tension Arc from hell's Paradise or
yukikaku's chico karaku obviously this
Arc was a major step up from the first
one where we kind of only learned about
the characters and the world that they
were in with us like here we learned a
lot more about you know the power system
in general with this Dao this mysterious
you know tencent or these seven
mysterious tents in that we've got
inside of um harai here along with the
three Landscapes that make up this
island issue Hojo and harai there's
other factors like this jifu character
that kind of make this all more
mysterious at the moment and you kind of
don't really understand the entirety of
this situation what's actually really
going on you get a little bit of a hint
where Rhian kind of drops the bombshell
and lets everyone know that she wants to
turn everyone on the mainland into tan
pretty much so that's the kind of like
big plan I guess you could say at the
end of the day but why do they want to
do that there's so many different
questions that need to be answered so
I'd love to know like what exactly you
think down in the comment section below
and just you know this is kind of the
Half Point Way throughout the uh Series
right here at champion of 59 out of like
127 so we are pretty much halfway
through so the next Arc is slightly
longer than this one here but uh yeah
give me another three weeks to get that
out and hopefully I'll have it out in a
similar amount of time before the the
anime ends and the same with the uh the
final Arc as well hopefully I can get it
all out before the animations all gone
well I've been working so hard to get
this all out of time actually putting in
the maddest hours so you know leave a
like down below push this video to 5K
likes again so that I know you want this
next part and just you know drop a
comment down below with your favorite
character and your favorite Point
throughout this manga so far it's
absolutely dope and I just everything
about it I think probably Mudan to me
his entrance and him showing up where
with user riha and hoco at the gate is
probably my favorite Point throughout
the series so far it's it's just
absolutely beautiful seeing the entire
scenery around and then you know
everything just changes from beauty to
Absolute despair in a matter of seconds
it's it's the epitome of what hell's
Paradise actually is it's Beauty and
despair incarnate in my eyes anyway but
obviously if you guys want to support me
even further unless and get earlier
access to these kind of videos like a
day early before I release them here on
YouTube then make sure you check out my
patreon which I will leave a link to
down in the description below and if you
are hanging around here I want to keep
up to date with all of the series that
I'm releasing like Jiu Jitsu Kai's in
Hell's Paradise Attack on Titan Demon
Slayer and even Tokyo Avengers
occasionally I'll probably get around to
that final I'll probably get her into
that fine Mark at some point but you
know like it it ends for me in tinjuku
man I tell you by the way you know if
you guys are new around here and want to
like see more stuff then make sure you
do subscribe but for now it's been
professional to generate diavolo and I
will see you all in a bit bye
foreign